une production du studio sf bio sans
filtre le podcast où on parle de ce
qu'on veut avec nos invités
dad j ph quand tu es avec moi le plan
cette semaine le sans-fil présenté par
15me 15me on s'est fait faire des
caisses de téléphone par la gagne de
caisse me william le cofondateur de kiss
me met en jeu les rencontres autrefois
puis modique y avait du monde qui avait
il y avait nos caisses qui avait haché
locace merci la gagne je voulais faire
partie du groupe
dirigez-vous vers le lien dans la bio
qui se met en fête c'est des caisses de
téléphones haut de gamme ça a été fondé
ensuite un projet universitaire par deux
beaucerons en 2016 leur usine est encore
à saint georges de beauce cdc tout fait
ici il ya 250 points de vente au québec
des semaines de troubles
rogers et ils peuvent faire faire des
caisses pour vous et si vous utilisez le
code promo sans filtre 20 lors du t4
j'avais écrit écrit dans la description
du podcast vous pouvez sauver 20 % sur
votre commande
donc merci a gagné 15 smith est une
compagnie québécoise avec qui on est
très fier de s'associer et allez vous
procurer vos caisses sans fil et les
podcasts est aussi présentée aujourd'hui
par planethoster on a même des goodies
bientôt c'est un petit pas d'os ou liés
à des trotteurs c'est une société
d'hébergement web pour vos sites web et
toutes vos besoins internes est alors
prête aussi c'est un support 24 heures
sur 24
david est question n'est pas de quoi ils
sont là ils sont bons sont rapides ils
vous expliquent ils sont vraiment doués
les clients prenaient trop souvent notre
site et sur planethoster ça va super
bien c'est super bien été s'inscrire le
transfert aux signaux donnés par sont
hébergés par une autre
ce site et l'hébergement avant ce super
bien été sécurité optimale pauvre site
web est également plus de soixante mille
clients qui sont clients prennent un
toaster ses bases et ça vient d'ici de
laval près précis super belle entreprise
avec qu'on est pas content tu te
présenter et inspiré des annonceurs
récurrent sur le centre fait comme notre
prochain annonce aussi la gagne de
terriens terriens naudé one nos
comptables en fait très intéressés un
bureau de comptable ça fait plus de 25
ans qui sont tous voir puis ont
développé une expertise dans les pme de
1 à 100 employés dans les domaines
d'avenir c'est à dire multimédia jeux
vidéo studio de podcasts vous avez pas
besoin de leur expliquer en fait vos
votre modèle d'affaires parce qu'ils
sont habitués de travailler avec des
compagnies dans ce milieu là puis
pourront vous aider à maximiser à
maximiser pardon votre tour des crédits
d'impôt recherche et développement
cedeao et multimédia en plus d'offrir un
système d'impartition comptable ça ça
veut dire que si vous voulez que t'es
rien de rien c'est charge de la
comptabilité dans votre entreprise
ils peuvent devenir votre département de
comptabilité en fait pour un tarif qui
est très avantageux pour des pme dont
vous allez pouvoir prendre cet argent là
et la mettre dans votre compagnie donc
aller sur terrain trait d'union cpa
point com pour plus de détails toutes
les infos dans la description du podcast
sinon extrêmement excité par la
conversation de cette semaine on a reçu
rachid badouri à une mort est des plus
connus au québec et aussi en france 1 go
qui est arrivé dans le monde de l'humour
mi-2001 et mi-2002 maliki est arrivée
comme une bande qui a tout déchiré
piquets depuis cartonne partout où il va
et on s'est fait un peu plus tranquille
salaires années mais revient avec un
nouveau spectacle pour 2020 un spectacle
qui va encore une fois tout arraché
c'est certain rachid badouri qui
récemment fait un jeu
le coming out en fait que avoué
publiquement il n'y a pas dans son
spectacle être avoir été un trou de cul
longtemps expliquent qu'ils pètent et
décoche qui était plus toujours gentil
avec les gens mais qui travaille avec
aussi les gens dans sa vie proche de lui
pillot régler ses problèmes apparemment
y consulter il ya vraiment fait un
cheminement personnel puis il nous a
parlé ici on a parlé longtemps par des
conversations sur justement comment
devenir meilleure personne
comment régler ses problèmes les
avantages aussi de le consulter qu'on a
des certains démons qui nous ronge
je suis pas touchant mais aussi super
drôle parce que on s'endort c'est un
humoriste il a fait des imitations de
foi d'eddie murphy de tous à des
doublures qui fait on a vraiment ri mais
on a aussi réfléchi et ont été touchés
c'est cette semaine si vous aimez nous
entendre parler psy vous êtes ici en ce
moment en train de nous écouter même à
travers les annonces qu'on fait en début
de podcasts et que j'imagine qu'on vous
fait pas trop chier on a un autre
podcast qui s'appelle sans filtre vip
qui est disponible seulement à nos
membres et tu en as conçoit des gens
moins connus que dans le sens filtre
mais tout aussi intéressant cette
semaine a reçus lambert qui se trouve à
être notre nouvel employé ici au studio
et cf qui nous aident
je me rappelle plus comment qu'ils
appellent le département qui s'occupe
roi des quelque chose en prod laisser
choisir son titre fait que vous dirigez
sur notre page pétrone c'est également
la meilleure façon de nous encourager et
faire partie de la communauté payton
on va éventuellement ça fait longtemps
qu'on en parle faire un spectacle live
on ne peut pas encore plus de détails
mais il ya de bonnes chances que les
membres et rihanna aille avant première
sur les billets donc on va on va revenir
là dessus quand nous aurons plus
d'informations à ce sujet là sinon peu
importe la plateforme sur laquelle vous
nous écoutez présentement les signaux
commentaire laisse non writing les snobe
les signaux en choeur les signes ou tout
ce que vous pouvez nous laisser
laissez nous le
sinon alfonsi non là c'est tout et
bonbons podcast bonne écoute
[Musique]
merci beaucoup d'être sinon merci mais
vite et ça fait plaisir on était super
content de recevoir le courriel c'est
sylvie séduit ça va on était ultra
contente et cris racistes et à la suze
écoute est allé plusieurs fois j'étais
allé une fois puis après je t'avais fall
celui de péri des jeux comme
j'expliquais attendant les jeux du
commonwealth est la seul endroit où ce
que moi personne qui parle trop j'ai pas
de limite pour par les endroits parce
que des entrevues télévisées ou non on
peut attendre
on peut dans tout les sujets on avait
justement d'écouté évidemment le ton
d'entre eux vers tome on en parle quand
tu es quelqu'un qu'on a reçu un email
puis en écoutant son entrevue ce que je
me dis à ces crimes je prendrai vraiment
plus de temps pour élaborer sur surtout
cela qui pue la presse après son nul
aimé le fait que ça tombe un corps
humain avec plaisir moi je mettrais
peut-être plus de volume parce que je
m'entends un saut ça se sait atteint
jusqu'à 4h ce choix d'accord mais pas
que la jeunesse dans des clubs que je
fréquente moins de retour pour la
deuxième partie d'exercice je risque
d'un père jean aux diktats des cons se
promenait on se rend dès lors vers 1h du
mat est entendue on y est déjà content
et ça mon beau frère puis moi et oui je
sais on animait des mariages ont des
fins de mois
piste est un peu arnaque ce qu'on avait
mis comme publicité on avait dix
professionnels du professionnel
animateur depuis longue date et pis on
voulait vraiment faire ce qu'on a marqué
des niaiseries sur la fiche mais on
assuré sauf que moi je m'améliore en
tant qu'animateur mais lui il s'achetait
des mx2 déjà fait faisait comme si mixer
les l'espère m'emmener n'était pas reçue
il le juste enregistré d'un club 2 1
samedi soir là il restait chez eux puis
je suis comme prix le mix de minuit à 3h
ok ok là le mec sa radio sur un cd live
qui ai fait ça puis dans un mariage
foutu ça je suis peut-être s'est trompé
peut-être qu'il agite la prendre pour
avoir des idées de musique mais où tu te
plais l'isla puis - le shoot 'em jetons
soir j'ai fait le triomphe est très
élastique sa part on à le porter et pony
lui fait c'est que son épouse feue
torticolis de passe qui était cadrée de
façon permanente en outre 8 cm à lui
parce qu'ils comme lyon c'est comme
baisser visite est vraiment incarné au
pyla crédibilité s'est permis d'aller
didier qui mettent des protections
célèbre du monde
juste enregistré des kings des coups il
rendu par barcelone va prendre des
comics a longtemps animé marine j'ai
fait ça fait c'est un bon un bon deux
ans on faisait les salons en tout cas
quelle année avant d'être
avant de me faire découvrir en 2005 que
je dirais de mai entre 2001 et 2002
jusqu'à 2004 2005 je peux plus c'est bon
ça s'est fait vite pour moi comme un
sujet assez rapide fait que je me
trouvais je trouve ça bizarre de l'animé
40e dans un sous sol
au début les fêtes ouais je dirais qu'à
une coupe de marié qui était content
parce qu'ils ont envie d'un festival
mais oui un gala autre chose ça me
retombe face à beaucoup aussi vu avant
d'être morisques d'ouest qui viennent
puis mettez formateur à faire ce domaine
des contextes que c'est quand même moi
fissiles pareil louey sûr surtout nous
parce qu'on avait des on attirait
beaucoup des mariages multiethnique
on l'accusé l'a vraiment vraiment quand
je te dis multiethnique du côté de la
femme du côté d'hugo d'une différence
énorme on a déjà fait des mariages
russes chinois huawei québécois latino
arabes musulmans très pratiquants le
voilier avec genre des latinos des
articles puis il fallait vraiment être
capable
ma job à moins c'est de réunir tout le
monde qu'est ce qu'on faisait souvent sa
fourchette beaucoup de monde sauf les
mariés parce que vous le faire la parité
c'est qu'on changeait les tables tillion
procédé mouradi bon faut pas jouer avec
lui lui vont tuer lui de faisait toutes
leurs plantes battue et de laisser
s'asseoir pour se calmer en 15 jours et
que c'était trop fret
c'est le jeter comme non non ça marche
pas souvent on veut juste très chic
notre paroisse effet le monde se lève
quand c'est un clinton de leur pays ou
si vous sous sa fac a demandé ce que je
faisais ce que je mélange tout le monde
disait je faisais un jeu de s'allier
avec la pauvreté absolue acheter comme à
précédent dans tout le monde sera soit
ça a marché au début de monde était un
peu résignés la presse a marché mais
pour répondre à ta question ça m'a amené
samassa marques ont battu ma gêne
ouais contrairement à ce qu'on peut
penser mouche nagui qui très timide très
gêné car une fois que sa part sa pop je
m'arrête plus un mais je peux être et
surtout dans un petit groupe c j'ai tout
de suite été projetés dans des masses on
vend des festivals je suis aurait été
dommage et offert un show devant deux
3300 personnes au saint denis avant même
d'avoir fait un spectacle ce soir c'est
presque un
c'est tellement plus intime dans vingt
personnes que tu vois leur fassent leur
site voici où nos masques une masse
comme à la radio t on par là pleinement
mon sens une personne mais moi ça m'a
aidé parce que c'est c'est quand tu
déranges du monde en train de manger la
main qui tout le canton c'est facile
mais quand t'es pas connu là son pas
venu pour te voir non lubie c'est pas
toi la suisse
ces nouvelles une belle leçon aussi de
comprendre que c'était pas toi la
vedette jeudi est mal compris le temps
mais cathy quand clef le couple se marie
la cu les substances tout est vraiment
laid j'ai vraiment hâte rappelle le
mariage de nos amis david avait 2 juin
vaut rien il est le masters de cérémonie
le cian healy comme take over
je découvre le parti mais comme c'est
bon d'avoir un encadrement comme me
déplacer lequel il faut se lever puis
chanté la toune de black eyed peas à
gala feeling mais comme tel à ma tante
qui viennent faire un speech tout le
monde est complet c'est une question de
radars ces faits devant la fougue du
centre que la ton jeu peut-être le
mettre de côté tu le feras semaine
prochaine en ton nom de maria loin le
sait peut-être le temps de laisser la
place aux stylistes accord vraiment bien
c'est puis la nuque sont partis un
exploit de se lever puis savoir s'ils
vont capoter et puis d'autres je pense
que c'est une gang de monde un peu plus
mollo - puis si ça ne peut pas sortir du
coup d'agadez feeling à chaque mariage
balles allemandes sont comme dassault
comme le veut à quoi je pense le monde
la plupart sont allés d'or téléphone la
demande la synthèse
ouais ça regarde mais cette espèce de
ligne a traversé ces deux tu viens
d'abord ton brigue plus il faut que
t'arrêtes les autres à former ce pas
facile afin que ces affaires le sait les
affaires qui trament net hon
il faisait payer ton appartient musique
c'est un peu la même chose c'est un
artiste qui fait son band the cover plan
mené ya comme ça explose de son côté
créatif tu le fais tu encore des absents
grenouille puis ce toit de tout de suite
fait attention
ouais j'ai été chanceux vraiment
chanceux parce que au niveau financier
j'ai été approché s'appelle robert
ayotte monsieur robert ayotte qui était
en dans le temps le pdg de loto-québec
qu' il était venu voir un des festivals
qui mais moi je te dis le audition au
mois d'avril 2005 comme ça ça ça a été
vraiment rapide le dati trognon girardot
qui m'a appelé pour faire allusion je
fais le festival juste pour rire de moi
après trois mois après je me rappelle la
dame à mon souvenir puis si on était
assez vieux en 2005 peau pour être très
conscient de ce qui passait dans mon
souvenir tu es vraiment arrivé d'un coup
d'un coup puis d'un coup c'était pareil
nouvel humoriste conséquent rock et d'un
coup c'est l'humoriste et déjà comme ça
j'ai pas longtemps restée une relève
ouais on a fait des choix même audacieux
c'est de faire une première au sein de
niort mêmes nous on n'y croyait pas pour
céder dans quelle merde on s'est mis
comme en convoi remplir sa personne ne
connaît si tout le monde en parle qui
nous avaient sauvé jusqu'à là tout le
monde en parle plus et ce n'est pas tout
le monde en parle comme tu vu
dernièrement à tout le monde en parle où
est ce que chaque occasion que tu as un
peu comme j'ai un accroc avait fait cas
qui était venue pour présenter le
nouveau festival et nassian au très
intelligent ce que l'on attendait 10
points l'entente d'époque tout le monde
parle de leur affaire lui était était là
pour supporter et elle a aussi pour
projet c'est tout le monde parlait que
de gêner la croissance mais il était là
pour penser aux 6000 pour donner son
support mais il a pris la case on sait
ce qu'on a fait
la bourse qui on
en même temps la musique des pédales put
puis parlait pas français ça je pense
aux américains puis guy hardy est une
horreur we gonna say i'm gonna say some
stuff les faits james bennett monde en
parle
le lendemain on croise les doigts dans
une semaine on avait 6 et 7 octobre
mais le tout voit petit espoir tu vois
pas le montage
oui j'essaie de punch et plus passent et
espère qu'ils vont en avoir le général
puis j'avais tout donné tout ce que je
pouvais je sortais certaine paix en même
temps c'est une émission un peu un peu
c'est politique c'est ça les invités
sont très variés que ça m'a toujours
matt et informationnels voilà que ce
système est était juste l'idéal un peu
sa cotées de moyennes un chanteur extra
de la belgique
salvatore son nom alpha bah non non et
non je ne sais la neige est même tout de
hyogo avec lui la commune s'appelle
salvatore quelque chose à nous inspirer
aux cités comme mais de quelle planète
vous descendez monsieur était comme tout
était parfait des moments comme ça dans
la villa jade et sweet mômes maintenant
est ce que tu souhaites que ce moment là
arrive là je veux tu peux sans compter
mais on est là pour ce que vous promet
un ferme ta gueule après 3 ans et les
envoyer vos dons
[Rires]
luisao fils j'étais je commence à être
connue au quai tranquillement j'avais
mon premier one man show au pilote et
moi j'ai tripé toute ma vie sur les
films de france de francis veber tout
les films de pierre richard
peut-être trop jeune pour ça mais pierre
richard puis gérard dépardieu dans le
temps ils ont fait une série de films
si tu veux te taper des bons vieux films
français la comédie une porte ouvre la
porte fermée va voir tout les films de
webber avec francis avec pierre richard
puis c'était un tout croche là il tomber
un club il grimpe ou cela puis un de ces
films qui m'a fait qui a participé les
compères c'est vraiment vraiment
vraiment vraiment bon et vous c'est à
dire à quel point son bon c'est fini à
peu près six de ses films qui ont
interpellé aux états unis puis ça fait
des succès monstre c'est une vraiment
vraiment vraiment bon puis pierre
richard largement rencontré de ma vie
j'avais une fois ou deux en france
puis on arrive au vieux porche avec
toute ma famille pour né à la place
cartier ou est ce qui la place dans un
endroit où est ce qu'il ya comme des
amuseurs de rue une qui pourront
regarder tout ce que j'avais ma petite
nièce avec moi sur mes épaules
je me retourne puis je vois pierre
richard et l'espagne j'arrête ma famille
ce qu'est ce qu'on fait bonjour non mais
si jamais c'est une bonne personne
il va le voir j'ai un chalet du brésil
l'équipe du brésil sont plus variables
bonjour monsieur genre je voudrais je
suis un grand fan f1
merci puis se retourne puis s'en va
hélas envoyez moi quelque chose pour
qu'ils regrettent sûrement mal aux tiges
blais j'étais comme tu comprends pas
j'ai grandi avec toi ce tweet mené à la
chance de comprendre et de faire ça de
de dire que c'était possible il était
que la musique comme tout objet t il ya
un moment donné je te jure de nulle part
et je vous ment paul il ya un autre bus
jaune qui arrive du parc devant le
devant la place il la porte s'ouvre puis
il ya une jeune fille qui combine
je pense qu'à les tours dans le dans
l'autobus aoulad syad corps et passeur
ça fasse demain pas fait puis le boss
bouchemaine il sort dans une impasse au
québec lors des comités comme un gars
j'ai fait comme 200 figurants qu'on a
dit on a payé c'est un piège d'un avec
des coupons mcdonald's est un geste vers
fou quand ils me voient vire fou place
aux vins qui me lève une amuseurs de rue
se retourne y arrête 6 brûle que max
hadorn pierre genre se retourne aux
pieds des filles des [ __ ] la crise le
bordel gt gt le che guevara je dois
pirates avaient spire partent vite comme
dans un film une comédie musicale mamma
mia la fin de la danse c'est pure ni lé
riskab méthode mettant tous dans leur
tête à ce moment là combien ça prend du
temps ces petits segments lopy après ce
combien tu penses à nos prix réellement
dans ma tête ça a duré 30 secondes mais
je pense a appris comme littéralement
saint simeux dette parce qu'elles
chauffent à ses franchisés vous
débarquez genevois jeter le bonheur eu
une fille qui gomme qui faisait comme
c'est comme si tous les feux sont
rentrés dans le boss sont partis et ma
femme vient me voir demain face à voix
derrière mon épaule pierre et shorts
serviettes il s'enrichit qui est il
servit un pays riche en raison d'une
tendinite à l'épaule les sortants ont
fait le coup du je fais oui mais quand
je faisais je suis un artiste puis une
déraison plaquage fait du mot c'est une
grande source d'inspiration
d'accord je crois que vous étiez un jour
du brésil
la caméra détecte éléments pour moi tu
sais je suis un c'est votre meilleur la
neige tombée une bouteille de vin non là
je sais combien est relatée par marc et
espace pour ramasser les morceaux de
glace il allait vite est super gentil a
dit madame pour regarder moi madame
c'est ma dixième but est que je casse
aujourd'hui c'est du vinaigre
[Rires]
j'étais comme une intervention et
surtout à éviter ça qu'elles sont
parties 1 c'était qu'ils sont ne sont
pas arrivées sont partis assez
rapidement que lui sans naipaul ouais
c'était comme un conte où nous on n'a
pas de bol c'est le assez vite c'est
comme on devrait se créer une agence de
je voudrais montrer que oui ouais à
demande que tu votes facteurs engage en
autobus de mars et même au début ça
chaque fois et que les mêmes jeunes
petit prince et speed dial ce fait j'ai
besoin de vous dans douze minutes et je
vous parle à personne via des systèmes
de location de voitures qui sont à
toutes fins pratiques pour ce
sous-vêtement de rouler en lamborghini
les décroche de vie qui roule en
lamborghini qui est loué pour la journée
trois compagnies
n'a pas loué la partie son ami chose
déjà des stands à la halle à ce travail
si l'export de son hôtel du centre-ville
de montréal pelli compétitivité
d'ensemble il rembarre plus j'ai pas vu
ce qui s'est fait distancer rappelle
david à bhl en plein centre ville de
bourges et c'était fou le seul et
apparemment tout le monde pensait
vraiment qu'il était saoul qui était
complètement saoul il policiers de le
ramener à la maison
ça va monsieur sont gentils nasa alors
elle dit les français sont nos cousins
oui mais les belges c'est ce que c'est
ça qu'on dit me sens beaucoup qui vont à
la façon qu'ils sont ouais je pense que
les fonctions prochain je le dis dès
fois mais met aux paris pète le reste de
la france
paris c'est ça ressemble pas trop à
montréal au niveau de commandes ni mais
je te dirais qu'entre bruxelles et à
liège sont vraiment bien plus teyon on
dit free de fait ces coins là pas mal
oui
dans toute ma carrière j'ai vraiment été
chanceux d'humoristes québécois qui a le
plus tourné en france je pense pas je
pense courtemanche et indigo qui
tournait plus en france où avant moi
kavanagh a été un des gueux tourner les
pouces en france rousseau voilà je
dirais j'arrive un quatrième mois j'ai
réussi à lâcher grèce a mis beaucoup
énormément
qu'est ce qui fait qu est-ce qui fait
maintenant que ton humour à toi
s'exporte aussi bien moi j'ai hâte et je
sais pas de pierre richard n'ont pas de
pierre richard j'ai grandi et que la
triple culture chez nous j'ai grandi
avec la culture québécoise et lundi à 10
ans les premiers festivals du port et
moi j'ai rien d'assez religieusement
puis mon père il ne pleurait souvent sur
tv5 aussi tout ce qui se faisait
je recevais beaucoup de cassettes
beethoven hs de mes cousins en france
qui m'envoyaient des sketches de jamel
debbouze dans le temps des inconnus
c'est quand même le groupe r&b au delà
bolt six fusées des numéros à sketches
puis vraiment grandi avec ça on y allait
souvent pour se rencontrer souvent au
maroc et que notre ami de la france fait
que j'ai tout de suite su veux pas que
ce qui se faisait les premiers rap
français benny b compagnie les groupes
d'ailleurs j'ai vraiment grandi avec ce
facteur pas dépaysés quand j'arrivais là
puis l'on se pare en joual mais je sais
pas pourquoi quand j'arrive en france il
ya un genre de france est s'est pas
forcé sassou est un peu d'attentes
auxquelles continuent de montrer une
vidéo digne de toi avec le chef français
changent un peu ton accent ça deviens tu
pas parler cruel mais c'est ainsi
mais tout peut arriver avec un accent un
peu plus populaires un pisse et c'est
tout à ton avantage parce que s'ils ne
comprennent pas c'est ce regard souvent
d'entendre les chanteurs ils ont un
accent incroyable en anglais puis quand
il se met à parler mais on s'en fout
c'est la musique qu'on veut entendre
c'est tes paroles mais ça même chose
pour nous autres satisfait pas
comprendre le monde vont poser en fait
ta poche mois de un peu le parler un
petit peu comme ça fait que je pense le
fait que j'étais moins dépaysé quand je
suis arrivé là et mes premiers chaussons
pas comme mon nouveau show en ce moment
et est très axé sur des blagues à
l'international et par là de michael
jackson c'est intemporel ton nouveau
choses se passent à la preuve elle est
beaucoup plus personnel
fwi et des numéros qui vont se sont
parlé de certaines mes numéros c'est sûr
certains n'ont pas raison mène ces
essais c'est l'approché pareil c'est
juste beaucoup plus profond mais ça
reste une thématique choisie universel
que n'importe qui peut en plus se
rejoindre oui parce que tu parles
d'accouchement tu parles de tes
positions sur l'homophobie sur la
xénophobie sur sur le sexisme axa suis
citoyen au mcs tarifs c'est pas moi je
n'attends droit ou sexisme sexisme est
ce que est ce que sa patience était pas
un pays par pays mais ça passe mieux en
france que les dos des kilomètres armes
et on le sait ouais que des références
non mais tu vois ces pactes et de
référence est québécois le tir de jean
louis côté geneviève la guerre il est
trop maison sans toit ni le rôle comme
il s'appelle notre un contexte de marché
en france plus et peut s'étendre cette
entrée dans le mondial et mais quand qui
vole mon me le dis je jouais dans la
même salle que lui puis j'ai demandé par
curiosité j'ai rempli du cac et des
mondiaux à chaque fois fred pellerin qui
change si ce mythe zéro compromis
explique des fois et changer le mode tac
pour télé oui des mots on au juste si
des fois je dis aux gens qui sinon il y
aura vraiment une déconnexion pure gens
qui vont là je vais aller voir rat
conteur québécois
je vais me déchirer les oreilles pour
bien comprendre je vais absolument je
vais rien boire pour être sûr que je
suis dans son île c'est en vendant ses
thèmes au-delà c'est comme aller au
musée pour aller voir une belle
exposition de la chine une chose comme
ça exactement ils s'en vont là pour ça
mais quand est un humoriste qui fait
partie de la masse des humoristes en
france faut que tu te fous qui tenait à
la main son entrevue
justement tu lis très fier je vais rien
changer dit que je resterai en france
demande du baril de brent burns du quoi
ces gens étaient plus je veux dire c'est
comment qui marient ou du moins que rien
c'est gratton de la france tous supports
du coin du bois y avait aussi prédit
bien des lentilles et benti premier jour
j'avais fait je parlais vraiment joêl
auditifs 108 ans qui skie qu'est ce qui
dit le battre il pleut qu'est ce qui lie
ça faisait si vous sonne en expliquant
tous n'ont pas les colts ont c'était
vraiment drôle il y avait égalé il ya un
endroit où est ce que je pense c'est
énorme et anglaises françaises
puis le guide qu'est ce qui dit on les i
c'est qu'est-ce qui les hissent à la
poésie c'est qu'est ce qu'ils foutent
halal avoir une grande culture delà de
l'humour quand on met les mots je sais
pas comment dire le visuel pas
nécessairement visuel mais comme
appelons ce aux coudes oui aux recteurs
vraiment une bonne qu'ils sont illégaux
je m'excuse mais je suis un peu et j'ai
42 ans non mais que non non j'ai
consommé beaucoup de noms mais beaucoup
beaucoup j'étais attiré par sa puis le
mot humoriste n'était pas très c'est pas
très bonnes références n'était pas un
mot qui revenait souvent quand on était
jeune puis dans ma tête jusqu'à un
certain âge ça appartenait à un certain
groupe de gens de là yvon deschamps
j'avais pas ce profil là dans ma tête je
savais pas que j'avais quelque chose à
raconter qui pourrait peut-être plérin
public c'est le modèle encore au québec
non non c'est juste qu'à tant que c'est
pas pour faire du promu qui culturalisme
mais c'est vraiment quand anthony puis
courtemanche aussi parce que
courtemanche je moi je l'aï vu la
première fois c'est sûr la télé comme
tout le monde mais je l'avais vu en live
pour la première fois au cégep je
faisais partie d'une équipe s'appelle le
mémorial dont je me serais de foot
dehors parce que je mangeais trouve
époque fait que mon mais rien de
l'équipe école mais qu'un que je me
souhaite faux d'orge quand même été bon
joueur est allé voir un match des
nouveaux contre les anciens dont faisait
partie michel courtemanche martin petit
et ken scott guy lévesque
comment s appelle notre acteur comédien
né dans toutes les séries incroyables le
goût de louis godin pro énormément il y
avait aussi il y avait sévi moreau s'est
inquiétée à soissons je m'en rappelle
plus brefs délais regardez puis je
voyais michel courtemanche chuter caen
mène ces gars là ça me parle ça me parle
beaucoup beaucoup parce que très
mimiques très physique et en même temps
j'adorais imiter fois que j'aurai à
toutes les femmes d'eddie murphy quand
j'étais jeune les beverly hills
j'écoutais pas en anglais dont je
comprenais pas l'anglais j'ai regardé
vraiment en français parce qu'elle avoue
a été écrite sur la voie d'une âme avec
juste une courte parenthèse maintenant
vos emails ma blonde aa voulait aller
prendre des cours d' d'acting vocale à
quai puis la personne qui répondait sur
son répondeur
il y avait il y avait deux options de
répondre à la première répondeur c'était
le gars qui faisaient la voix de bruce
willis un fake faisait bon jour c'est
moi bruce willis veuillez laisser
message suivant vous rappellera l'hôte
stade français s'ils répondent répond à
regarder non mais tu peux appeler le
passé
vote explique pourquoi parce que dans
temps avant internet
moi je tripais sur cette voie là je
savais pas que ça plaît med hondo med
hondo qui est décédé l'année dernière en
passant était sa passion c'était
réaliser des courts métrages des longs
métrages beaucoup de docu mais dix-huit
films de tous les personnages noirs dont
eddie murphy à polonais faisait saisir
les toiles aux îles à ses plus hauts
laissez pas dragon je vais te casser la
gueule à quémander chichi nous on s'en
moque racing club ne prépare sort de la
douche pis la télé jouets soulever la
poste le câble c'était d'en avant avant
le poste que qui se passe en ce moment
là qu'a tâche est telle qu'à bloquer un
poste qui comme un peu gratos le c'est
quoi cette affaire le nom il faut
beaucoup d'entrevues beaucoup d'affaires
de sucer dessus quand je prends mes
hockey me paye ma tv mater vécu bon
avant ma tv ça s'appelait le le cob le
poste du câble piscine comme des intrus
de tout les pays du monde il va la
caravane du maghreb y avait ici afrique
c'est quelque chose qu'on me sort puis
il y avait un poste qui jouait sur
justement un truc d'afrique j'écoutais
pour moi je me changeais je me mettais
des cheveux par la période gino ses
portes à un moment donné
je ma chance puis j'entends bien venu
mais d'où nous à montréal
comment trouvez-vous notre ville j'ai
succès votre première fois ici j'adore
cette ville je connaissais je dois
prendre un kilo d'innovation les gels et
le vin sur moi une pièce
j'attends cette ville est extraordinaire
les filles sans peine les mecs sont cool
je reviendrai si merde
le jeu fait quoi le j'appelle mes gosses
diot je vous rejoins au club mais comme
certains de l'arpette générique pour
voir si qui fait qu'à la fin invité
spécial med hondo jeu mais ceux là
dessus et il n'ya pas d'internet dans ce
sens là y'a rien fait que vous je fasse
mes recherches moi-même j'appelle un de
mes amis qui habitent en france the way
est très connue [ __ ] je trouve ça mais
on n'a jamais suscité qui jusqu'à temps
que j'arrive en france mais ce tango
l'homme a fait capoter
c'est toutes les voies d'eddie murphy
s'est mal en pis moé décide à les penser
puis je voulais on l'avait invité en
spectacle il y avait dit oui mais tu es
très mal à le faire mais le challenge de
dana minutes moi je voulais absolument
comme n'étant loges après désir et sa
tante
vous avez bien rejoindre la boîte vocale
de rachid badouri ce connard et ans et
elle est occupée en ce moment rappel le
après fais pas chier mec c'est je
voulais je voulais que vous et c'est
juste la meilleure joe gibbs il m'a fait
triper sgo lol tu mets ça en anglais
excuse moi pour aider mon fils lui même
mais sa voix est plate est plate
rocchi en anglais assez plat bruce
willis
c'est un peu la même que tu fais là
votre qui sont cas de changer leur voix
c'est le même gars qui fait ses talons
fesses et le talent ont depuis fait vous
suffit de
dans johnson entend même ils veulent lui
doit et doit avoir un bon qu'il faisait
là j'ai peur mais qui j'ai eu peur je
veux la vérité je te lis j'ai peur j'ai
peur savons aussi qu'il faisait ça la
voix de son beau frère un peu de folie
une folie politique et avait amené la
polo entraîné requis dans le trot puis
je faisais partie faisait pas clos mais
patricia de gauche claude apolitique
c'est parlant des faits non non non 36
ont gonflé la mort suspecte de tabasser
par nasion pression cérébrale passe
comme si en france il raconte l'histoire
ici avec ses poings s'est il pas de
coups bas pas de coup du lapin
dès que la cloche sonne chacun dans
votre coin c'est compris c'est compris
fait pas des excuses mobilisés on verra
d'ailleurs on verra indoor et yannick
exil à l'école si je ne sais pas si les
jardins film c'est le genre de fille moi
ce que les voix en français sont
tellement importants dans notre marque
on les retient mais je te conter ce soit
dans notre foi j'écoutais lefebvre et
bradley cooper
lady gaga lady gaga avec ma mère ma
soeur au chalet puis on l'avait sur
super écran français
puis la voix de bradley cooper se tient
tout le long du film dont l'impression
que ces genres un gros pervers faire
jouer il a comme tout le long du film tu
t'attaches pas aux personnages en bois
découpé par se distinguent route est
très important
ni ont changé la voix d'anthony hopkins
j'écoutais beaucoup qui m'ont dit le
gars arrêtez de faire sa voix
puis c'est un autre gars qui leur trip
c'est vraiment plate comme moi mais j'ai
retrouvé la voiture qu'ils n'ont en
effet les cocus de dossi me stages y
retrouver le jeu encore une fois je
l'avais laissé le poste jouer je me
faisais un déjeuner j'entends genre une
reprise une mission là soit près de chez
toi états unis ça se passe j'entends le
17 septembre 1988
mike johnson avait rentré chez lui pour
la dernière fois
c'est la voie d'un débat qu'il avait
sorti son couteau pour la première et un
petit peu comme château maintenant
j'étais comme un gosse n y avait pas de
case et pris des cours de diction maryse
ganivenq et madani cours de jeu pris 4
courtrai que premier ministre et premier
ministre
cet exercice piscine un peu de la plus
de jeu aussi qui a fait la voix de lisa
simpson bay merci à ma femme a fait
savoir qu'ils allaient jusque imiter sa
voix mais c'est à lui qu'il fasse mais à
moffett ces quatre personnages devant
toi non
les gays qui faisait fi et délits mots
ça québécois petit geste est fort il
veut conquis un film qui a passé à
travers toutes les générations ce laps
de temps et occitane tantôt juste avant
le podcast ont parlé lisanne nadeau
design c'est le goal heures au début dé
slapshot louis georges tin sport selon
lui le sait le grand père d'élise en
amont
un moment et affine story de son grand
père
le moi je crie watts phoques chassés ces
tongs remporte logiquement de m'envoyer
un vidéo de lui qui dit c'est que j'ai
demandé de dire j'ai demandé de dire de
quoi comme ça c'est une pénalité peu
palois de fer sur les types il le fait
il l'a fait j'ai un vidéo the sugar qui
me dit mon pea ch sur une pénalité mon
pays n'a pas de sens de garder ça moi je
gardais est arrivé ici du maroc que ma
soeur il y avait 1 1 un golf sur qui
capote est rejetée jubilait tripet sur
lui trip est pas mal on a fait une des
émissions peu qu'on ait des rachid que
j'animais on a fait un sketch avec lui
puis j'ai dit s'il te plaît tout juste
été bonne fenêtre manip le cd voix qui
te rappellent des souvenirs à lui mon
estime on va souhaiter une bonne fête
collet physiquement par tél
puis pleurer à sa fin c'est le plus beau
cadeau pour lui c'était pour lui au
québec
il fait moins la femme qui la voix m'a
marqué c'est happy gilmore français d
adam s'agit enfin c'est bon c'est quoi
les phrases cultes comme je me l'étais
les chais pas tout faire et tout revient
ici bas et il n'aura pas sa pote et à
kaunas
mais ouais mais comme si j'avais écouté
je comptais ses fans gays la route les
qui sorti d'impasse et ça m'a donné la
chair de poule c'est que cette seule
ride
horrifiée par gore s'est passé le jardin
film qui était qu une fois ceci c'est
pour moi c'est ce genre de film tekken
une fois ces deux fois pis mais moi au
contraire je trouve ça cool de récolter
parce que quand tu sais c'est la geek
squad qu'est ce qui se passe dans le
film
ces remarques prennent à moi mais qu'un
succès le deuxième producteur mon ami
marc antoine qui posent pas moins
d'anglais avec un petit jardin
marquantes on n'a pas ça y est qu'ils
les voient en français le genre tu étais
toute l'attention du film qui est dans
les dialogues et puis comme les petits
les petits malaises l'ipsi of pi lo en
français mais comme on l'a évacué fait
que l'on écouté le film +8 et comme si
justement là toutes les build up était
complètement marchés publics aux
[Rires]
doublages doubler les animaux c'est
juste des animaux un chien comme un
renard
ah non j'ai fait quand même un film
d'animation québécois qui s'appelait
s'était agi oublie le nom c'était super
le fun
c'était bien fait en plus 100 %
québécois la création c'était à la
recherche d'un besoin urgent de bigfoot
la nuit et y ait si il y avait moi il y
avait un peu plus tôt il y avait les
noms qui s'appelle chaque fois qu'on les
mette ils font des pirouettes là il fait
du parachute
guillaume guillaume lemay thivierge 3
s'il est mort aussi je pense à ceux
[Rires]
générés nerfs booster l'école télé
concours des génies en herbe c'est
d'égal dans les écoles puisque son
télévisé puis une école contre une autre
piste est l'école de deux genres nous
dit là vraiment là c'est dégoûtant tavel
autre état gens obsédés des paumés de la
ville
à chaque fois qu il vend une question bo
derek
bob herbert le progrès chaque fois je
regarde équipes de toute cette
génération le qui sont assagis après le
sait je pense à marc labrèche à guy
jodoin un bain à toute la gamme des
herbes et aux ce genre de clip le pis de
sketches où tu fais comment jamais de la
vie
ça existerait aujourd'hui ont été les
temps changent les moeurs changent aussi
petit tir mais si c'est pour moi il ya
la page 6 3 n'a pas atteint des pics les
petits citoyens à part mais pour la
génération avant moi crb auj
c'est tellement tig si comme on en parle
qui dit quand même assez politically
correct même si on sait que ça dérape
pas tant rb os x un maillage les textes
aiguisés quel point g il ya sorti une
phrase il était comme écurie
c'est un gosse qui gêne pas oui je pense
qu'il faut qu'on fasse attention pour
l'émission me gêne pas c'est ce que tu
vois de lui ce que je tombe en amont
d'amitié plus parce que c'est ce que
fera t il et si ces points à ce point de
façon violente à 4-4 sur le swiss
gatwick en suisse oui quand on le suit
sur twitter
quand je suis sur twitter la voix sur
les outils et tweets ce qu'il veut quand
il veut et puis s'il veut rentrer dans
un bis favec bière car l'iran une
mission qu'elle entrait dans un taxi je
pose dans une ville de l'ouest canadien
puis 10 speak white speak white le
guillou sinon c'est raciste et
francophones puis le gueulard a dit
comme ça c'est fait
qu'est ce que vous y avez répondu à la
tenue de la demande juste 10 - denis
jeudi mais dit d'un ton le jeu des cas
on a été faire des entrevues pour la
peau qu'on a fait ensemble
il ya un gars qui s'est pointé en estrie
il y avait des journalistes qui étaient
là bien xxi pointe et que son
magnétophone chez.com ans qui rentrait
la steg qui s'est improvisé journalistes
ont été jugés pas de ceux qui ont des
podcasts aux affaires comme ça où des
eaux des blogs ou des mais lui s'est
improvisé pires entré lopy déjà c'est
réussi à rentrer enregistrer un bagage
et saper les gens qui étaient là dès les
gros journaux qui était le plus fait
ouais guillot la rumeur voudrait que les
faits qu'elle fait non mais bof la
question non mais je te pose la question
quelle rumeur
regarde moi de quelle rue main pas
besoin de quelques mois je voulais me
cacher et ses dunes c'est d'un calme mon
sujet je le faisais avec avec m'ont
énervé marche paraît très agressif
recasement viola mais l'huile fed ainsi
va fermer ta oui je verrai on va y aller
il ya un vieux club de toulon apparaît
aussi télé vidéo les montages la tagline
est la musique parle le tag rêve de guy
lepage c'était c'est ça c'était une
saison 2
par les cmn critiqué par les radios de
québec puisse c'est que c'est de
l'argent public du la gogauche sexy show
plaisir j'ai fait le calcul
l'émission coûte à chaque citoyen 25
cents et jamie impôt de 25 cents à
l'accueil de radio canada
si vous n'êtes pas content vous venez
chercher votre vincennes picole et c'est
moi patients
oui oh oui mais surtout quand c'est
quand même des personnalités publiques
l'éthique qui a mené c'est comme la
goutte de trop
c'est la ferme la porte à quoi que cela
donne ma préférée avant le times et
gregory charles est invité à re quelle
émission avec passé francis reddy
l'animateur puis il dit c'est ton show
c'est super bon mais dictée c'est comme
vous improviser et puis c'est ta santé
oms a vraiment raide dingue mais des
fois on se sent pas inclus un trip de
gang puis ce que je trouve qu'il points
faibles ils le regardent dit moi je
trouve que le point faible c'est ce qu'a
toute part mais mais promet que prendra
que guillaume c sont même des personnes
qui est la plus intimidante à avoir
devant toi j'ai l'impression quand tu le
connais pour cela j'ai regardé ya en
chantant les louanges eux qui étaient à
tout le monde en parle le métier a faim
c'est quand même tu regardais beaucoup
d'avantagés
je pense que je passais juste pour
savoir pour aller chercher un peu de
croustillant du détail regarde maman
parce qu'il a vu à quel point le mélange
était était comme il te fera dans ce
qu'ils disaient allez sûrement il
expliqué un détail croustillant sont
beaucoup avancé ces noms seraient pas
cacher les fois où ce que guillaume on
va être intense c'est qu'un et nous tous
on va être d'accord avec lui
il reçoit quelqu'un un tout croche ouais
mais si c'est quelqu'un comme ça pour la
première fois c'est pas son style de
descendre ou quoi que ce soit non mais
je joue et je le disais pas censé viser
plus dans le sens je me mettais
facilement en place de ce que j'étais
nerveux parce que nous sommes moi j'ai
remarqué aussi gagné ne suis pas de
quatre enfants ici puis j'ai remarqué
que ça manque beaucoup
ouais c'est comme ça le met en garde si
qsi
enfin guillaume le souligne le gall la
chanteuse du monde capote tellement
talentueuse jean il a 17 ans cette
fille-là la tourette
ouais puis les personnes qu'ils voient
des fois mais ça ce vol avec ccnucc a
fait plus d fois à gauche à part à
droite puis c'est d'éthique surtout il
ya des choses comme des émissions devant
un public tout alors jetez pas d'une
gêne devant un petit public
si gênant moi je les fait 2-2 dimanche
le monde en parle je peux dire que
c'était pas de guillaume monteux homme
qui vit meurent avant chaud dans la loge
puis kenzy une question à la fois un
respire à la fois président n'oublie pas
la sincérité
c'est tout ce qui compte louis de
conseil
un bon conseil ont l'appui partie mois
serrer dans mes bras mon parti mais
n'oublie pas ta femme c'est mon idole
quand même gagné mon témoignage ce 12
juillet on sait ensemble tout de suite
mais je les ai vus après switcher
quindio chiite arrivée du parti
conservateur
ces salades c'est sûr certain que la fed
est addict a des comptes à rendre
mouillage écrit qu'outre ce qu'est ce
qui est excellent et et en furent
brouilla sorti d affaire chizy blood est
un fort penchant réponse en quoi
allez-vous vous déguiser ouais on la lui
n'arrive n'y avait pas capable de la dir
ses rivales à priori à la fin il a
convoqué à la voie à quoi allez vous
fixé dit à la fin bombardier alors j'ai
pas l'un allant chez pas mal est fait
merci madame bombardier faisait comme
jacky aux accords pris moins de 100
euros avec non il anges pour la tire
c'est pas parce que ces pays pour des
questions difficiles mais il est répondu
oui il va pas de 34 fois la première
fois que ça arrive je ne connaissais pas
on n'avait pas encore fait de films
ensemble c'était pas mon ami pense qu'on
sait pas puisque c'est lui qui m'a dit
tu es tu un pédophile c'est quoi sinon
c'est un maniaque luz n'ont pas toujours
assez jeune on a dit un icap aussi
humoriste parce que c'est sa profession
de base du cégep d'un humoriste a
grelotté adipi 2 de parts en faire juste
sincère mais sincère dans ce que tu dis
des choses que tu peux pas parler tous
parlent pas mais ya des choses que je
pouvais lui parler de jésus en mai mais
reste sans ce que tu vas répondre que ça
soit sincère c'est juste qu'on veut au
québec on a tellement dit quand tu
connais un peu on a tout plein de cours
d'histoire le maison on s'est attardé un
petit peu pour comprenez qu'il ya eu de
l'abus en tabarnouche dans cette
province depuis la nouvelle france
jusqu'à demain aujourd'hui le clergé en
abusé financièrement sexuellement quand
on est la province avec le plus de noms
de villes commencent par 5 5 500 magna
et de la burqa par le québécois veut pas
se faire mentir de droite et erreurs de
droit tombée le québécois la québécoise
avait juste portugais se sait juste
année prend le temps pour te remettre
montaut reprendre quand je te dis tombe
ça va poser vos amis du monde mais pas
le droit de faire des gâteaux faire des
erreurs constitue sûrement c'est vincent
lacroix qui avait été arrêté c'est est
impardonnable
vincent lacroix qui avait comme
fraudeurs goy de plusieurs millions $
des gens qui étaient toutes leurs
économies
c'est inacceptable c'est aussi pire
qu'un meurtre parce que je vois
peut-être fort mais c'est inacceptable
chez les ch et le québécois la
québécoise de se faire mentir de se
faire cracher dessus des 10 émissions
comme je marche très bien parce que ça
aussi politique
on veut que nos jeunes s'engagent à
voter tout mais en même temps on adore
parce qu'on est comme bien actions qui
vont nous rappeler rené lévesque en
atteindre même trudeau parent
mon père me disait tu as good as tu
pouvais pas l'aimer mais c'était dans ta
face à un d'époque life c'est je sais
pas s'ils l'ont fait avec lui mais moi
j'en ferais rien avec lui cédant tard
mon père est arrivé sans la crise
d'octobre
c'était welcome to quebec là un des
pires moments avec ma main c'est un seul
folle et un coup roulé du matin au soir
des rues d'hénin car il y avait des cas
fioul à des couvre-feux à 7 heures à 8
heures le soir mon papa doit de sortir
me raconter c'est mon père vécu la crise
d'octobre c'est phénoménal
puis il m'emmenait un journaliste qui
marchait avec tree dubaï pour le pour
les questionner jusqu'à sa demeure je
pense puis 10 comment mais en anglais
mais au rythme des saisies en dessinant
les dix jusqu à temps complet
les gars qui ont kidnappé le croise puis
la porte puis on va voir comment
internet d'où des jeux soit chez moi
j'arrive vidéo est belle un monte cristo
bombay étaient ils étaient balas c'est
may et théorie il est aujourd'hui telle
regarde par les petits fait comme ça
m'intéresse pas
c'est vrai que c'est un bas nylon le
pote on n'a pas été un peu connu et
reconnu qu'un an comme étant une figure
marquante le bain on a appris qu'ils
étaient figure massa n'est pas connue
mais des espèces de l'icom d'énergumènes
un peu oui comme ça mais vraiment oui
parce que j'en ai pas connu non la vie
éveillée de politique dure que j'ai rien
j'en ai c'est comme toujours du monde
corée c'est hier justin trudeau il a
embrassé dany puis après quand qui
repartit ils ont reparlé de tir denise
bombardier ramener quelque chose de
super intéressant a dit oui mais est en
campagne électorale
ce kit avait embrassé dans un autre
contexte qu'on veut c'est une question
se pose et qui est légitime - c'est la
vérité ils font toutes sortes de choses
pour être cool c'est jeudi raconte rien
qui est propre et qui s'appelle les
abattements al amari en activité des
activistes les autres lots ils
retournent leurs culottes six fois là tu
comprends c'est comme un sou de mon
expression je les ai inventées
aujourd'hui quelque chose de bon mais
bref
mais encore là quelque chose
rené leveret khl si tu veux aller voir
des vues speech de lui tu regardes
drogue c'est c'est c'était dans ses yeux
c'est là vous la fouille a perdu deux
référendums
1 y'a dit la vérité a sorti son cas et
je comprends ce que vous êtes en train
de me détendre me dis à la prochaine
fois c'est la prochaine fois c'était
foule cd mettons j'ai l'impression que
j'ai moi si je me trompe que greta
qu'est ce qui est en train de faire ça
va chercher ça un peu gelé ouais c'est
son discours à l'onu le team sky comme
tu vois que comme il ya quelques jours
c'est pas juste un discours qu'elle a
appris pika actes
elle recevra que ça va la chercher moi
je crois que les gens font comme oui une
vraie motion est formé de moi quelque
chose de vrai de voir quelque chose qui
pas ça tu as touché
oui ça peut être tout à fait moi à quel
point sa manche un bon fond d'écran
séguéla perd toutes ses photos cd sur
une jambe et gretel eagle parano
ridicule à la droite
qui fondent et des fonds ce que tu veux
sur un tee shirt
qu'est ce que j'ai fait j'espère qu'elle
va trouver parce qu'à chaque fois que je
montrais de quoi quelqu'un ça vous
arrive sur la loi de murphy tâche afin
de montrer quoi il faut que ça arrive ça
et tu sais quoi je vais dans le texte
aurait pu faire il s'est tu bouges pas
promettre une pause à l'international
que je ponds en couple si j'avais fait
un bond tee shirt il était vraiment bien
réussi
c'était pour la marche de vendredi pour
une émission avec avec le assez bon avec
son doigt né en en face moi m'a frappé
mais qu'est ce que les autres
l'opposition à qui s adresser
qu'est ce que c'est quoi la première
chose qu'ils ont faite de quoi ils ont
accusé dans la benne d'un de son de sa
maladie premièrement de sa maladie ce
qui est sûr le spectre de l'autisme qui
recherche du buzz jacques deuxièmement
ils disaient qu'ils étaient contrôlés
par quelqu'un du défi de césar comme ça
qui qui qui vraiment pour atteindre un
boss ferait tous cas le fait traverser
ce qu'elle a traversé c'est tout de
suite on a c'est de les taire on veut
quelque chose de corée on veut quelque
chose qui veut pas que ça dérange c'est
donald trump
on parle pas de lui aujourd'hui là je
sais qu'il déteste à travers la momie
une chose par contre que je capable de
sous-titré de ce colloque de dire c'est
qu'en dirait que ce que tu vois et vous
tu guettes mois et stupide
il est menteur alimentaires et des
propos homophobes et des propos
xénophobes ce il y en a plein c'est un
instinct ce point féministe pas tout
mais je n'ai si je pouvais je suis
surtout très s'appuie m dans un autre
homme politique comme un genre obama ou
quelqu'un d'autre
qu'est ce que tu vois c'est un peu plus
puis voix il va faire comme les anciens
rois ou ski vos chiens public va devenir
voix dimanche puisque c'était une
activité du temps d'antan de moyen âge
on va aller voir le choix le roi qui
dort c'est juste un jour c'était ça ça
reste alexandre avec me raconter ça
c'est aujourd'hui la même l'humour s'en
va vers ça pour ça que j'ai fait ce
tremplin là parce qu'ils m'ont ans je
vois avec la 40
j'ai envie de paraître plein de choses
je vais pas me cacher longtemps
longtemps longtemps à l'ego j'ai dit en
entrevue à rue à des amis la famille
qu'on a annulé notre mariage ma femme
qui mois en 2010 parce que je filmais la
pop puis 7 prenaient trop de mon temps
ce n'est pour prêt pour ce site est un
mensonge
c'est la vraie vérité c'est que je
voulais laisser ma femme parce qu' elle
aussi parce que ça marchait pas on se
pogner pis si possible sa maman mine
mais 41 années passées on en train de
s'asseoir avec un couple d'amis
sa cousine qui va se marier elle tout
jeune à 26 ans 27 ans lui aussi en bas
de 30 ans puis on parle on parle mais on
est tellement habitué de mentir là
dessus ça n'aide vraiment bon en vérité
way down est devenue une vraie vérité
par rapport à sion est là a dit écoutez
prenez votre temps parce que non en 2010
et je comprends que tu peux admettre qu
puisqu'il lui travail étudiant en
médecine puis travers à boston à dix on
a été à cause du film de rachid a annulé
puis j'ai arrêté à conversation comme ça
que j'ai faite chéri jeu combien de
temps on va mentir encore avec le cheval
sur la cuisson d'ailleurs charge en
outre en vaut elle absout je vole baroda
cpie mais la comprenais pas ce qui se
passait à partir sans rien de ferme qui
causent le g10 sa cousine j'étais niant
son mari jeudi
on s'est laissé parce que ça marchait
pas parce que j même dit je pense pas
que tu es la femme pour moi puis m
envoyer chier pas être sorti de l'auto
puis j'ai courait après à saint sauveur
dans les rues principales montmorillon
ce qu'ils veulent et qui court après
petite blonde gênera d'un fou rire dans
l'auto on va reparler bientôt n'ont pas
parlé pendant deux mois de recul et m'a
dit va te faire [ __ ] avec tes projets
c'est comme avoir qui fasse que j'avais
dit que j'avais fait à croire que
c'était 6 tc
c'était lourd la selo on a repris
ensemble puis j'ai fait faire un mariage
surprise
l'année d'après un gros mariage surprise
c'était fou le 6 mai mais j'ai dit aux
copains
vivez la vérité si vous n'êtes pas prêt
à nul on s'en fout vous êtes des
médecins vous allez faire de l'argent
des dentistes et médecins annuler s'il
faut annuler mais soyez vrai rush est
pas parce que vos parents vous ont dit
personne de ton à annuler le mariage est
remboursé des gens pour combler les
semailles au mexique quinzaine de
personnes j'ai remboursé ses amis on est
chanceux de fadeur des de bien vivre des
humoristes fait que j'ai remboursé ami
qui avait pas autant d'argent que j'ai
j'ai fait l'objet
puis pendant que je parlais legault y
manger ces nouilles me voulait tellement
pas entendre autant de vérités et yves
le juste à fait ok moi je veux savoir si
on devrait prendre des nappes roses ou
des centres de table enfin sur des
bateaux rapides j'irai mais j'ai dit non
même j'ai dit c'est jusqu'à quand on va
dire ces niaiseries la fecq moi
aujourd'hui ça me pue au nez et et j'ai
encore d'escalettes kashgar dans mon
placard où chaque chose a son temps
c'est quoi mais mais la plupart des
choses je les ai sortis dans mon show
que je sais live c'est là il ya eu des
engueulades il ya eu des choses
méchantes qui sont dus des affaires
aujourd'hui c'est ma première crème
seyman ma famille y arriver même pas une
feuille de papier qui peu passante
mobile et aucune décision qui se fait ça
elle est moitié mais que fait on n'a pas
le traitant comme des trucs qu on est
tous c'est super c'est quand qu'on ne
connaît pas qu'un collège comme fille au
public on le voit pas parce que en
entrevue ou un pull en d1 n'est pas non
plus parce qu'il y avait beaucoup de
monde qui sont nouveaux maudiront
l'entendent était enfant d'un ben moi je
sais on l'entend et ouais on attend qu
est un fendant mais est ce qu'on peut se
douter que c'est un fait on peut pas se
douter qu'ils étaient un truc tulle pour
optimiser leur dont on ne sait pas dans
quelle mesure dans commencent à se
décliner dans ta ville métier ça va
commencer qu'avec le succès au stade o2
avance
j'étais toujours un gars gentil généreux
c'est la fois des crêpes toi j'ai
toujours été un gars qui était son du
côté marocain est très hospitaliers mais
je peux t'aider coche je suis je n'ai
pas connu frais des grosses que je
montais sécurité moi c'est comme ça que
j'ai manifesté selon terre après glee
longue conversation avec lui c'est comme
ça que je manifestais ma part
insécurité y en a qui sont très
introverti qui vont se retirer en
acquitte rappelleront puna qui vont
disparaître pointeront pas l'émission -
quand ça marche approche péter une coche
ni grosse corde fixée par un public ou
dans jamais non justin mettant quelques
pas de vent pas devant les gens qui
connaissent pas maintenant dans devant
des équipes de plateau la vendetta ce
monde là c'est ce monde l'offre sur qui
je prêche pas été mais dis que le public
public ou la télé ou devant une caméra
c'était comme gt gt un as du maître du
déguisement déguisements et je te dirai
ça puis ce cette force là que j'avais de
pouvoir maîtriser mes dépôts parce que
parce que dans ma tête plus le public
mais mai puis me suivait plus j'avais
c'était même la raison c'était même le
mensonge que je m'étais donné pour
pouvoir me défendre quelqu'un qui m'aime
beaucoup me disait tu est en train de
dépasser les limites du maine au check
check les chiffes tchèque en plaques de
trois cent mille billets tchèque numéro
un des réseaux sociaux tchèque 6 check
the jicks j'avais tout à un mensonge pur
et dur alors dire pour mettre de côté
tout va bien puis quand je m'énervais
c'est ce que j'explique à tout moment
par mais je pensais le groupe istanbul
où je disais j'ai inventé un mot que la
dégueulasserie logic angers le mans
mon état dans mon état des deux galas se
cache dans son temps que je n'avais pas
encore fait face ouais j'avais mal pour
le mal que je faisais mais pas pour les
raisons que pour les bonnes raisons non
c'était plus pour dire et quand les qui
vont aller répéter sa carrière dans la
boxe assagi mais non fauche cash ça
c'est comme le gars qui bat sa femme qui
gère commencement je te juste jeu il
veut juste pas se faire pogner où le
gars qui vont encore paisible et 10 des
qui ressortirait recommencer conneries
c'était pas une réponse une réponse
c'est pas une repentance c'était
vraiment justin optimaux des bouteilles
de vin j'en à acheter des bouteilles
d'alcool pour m'excuser pas mon âge on a
amené même moment une femme avait dit à
demi creps et pas pour réparer des
petites conneries
elle savait savez savez à connaissent
eux
oui il écrit je faisais à maison ont été
faits tout autour de lever des réflexes
ne te disais que je marche porte monnaie
moi je pensais ça qui m'a sauvé c'est
qu'en bout de ligne je me suis rendu
compte que tout l'entourage que j'avais
n'est pas un là dedans que c'était pour
les mauvaises intentions
c'était ce qui m'émeut moi mes amis sont
restés 100% naturel réel comme qui sont
toujours là m'ont jamais vu comme une
vedette
je lui ai fait rire depuis l'âge de 5
ans en fac pour eux donc nouvelles
drogues de plus ou pas dans mes chansons
comme ça c'est le mac ce que je peux
avoir deux autres l'adq en six mois
jeudi fact et les autres
je suis resté le même rachid gt gt
vraiment un bon jack le stepper j'étais
un bon gauche peuvent faire rire mais
quand tout était plate était souvent
dans mon entourage tout leur marquer
rapidement que vraiment c'est
désagréable
ça peut aller jusqu'à une histoire de
table comme ça où est-ce qu'on est assis
maintenant on fête l'anniversaire de mes
amis dont une douzaine dans son réseau
un réseau d'une table dans un restaurant
on est douce mais moi j'arrive avant
tout le monde parce que je voulais avoir
le centre de table je voulais pas être
aussi parce que sinon je pense est
mauvais ce soir il fallait tout le temps
que c'est au milieu d'un bois qu'on aura
besoin
même quand on parle de [ __ ] à l'heure je
fais des efforts pour pas vous coupe la
parole c'est encore là ouais c'est
encore c'est juste qu'une conscience
puis il ya une grippe dessus c'est la
sphère convaincante hypothétique est là
le symbole des agissements
j'ai jeté la clé dans la serre je perds
personne arthro jeu pour personne des
bars seul avis ça doit devenir un genre
de au début c'est des efforts mais
éventuellement j'imagine que ça ça se
place je le souhaite pas soit que ça
reste le tagi comme un alcool et qui
restent calés que toute sa vie c'est la
même chose est un filiale reportage de
gueule ça t'es trop n'ont pas ces sexes
en attendant à paris
je n'ai pas encore écouté il ya j'aurais
dû passer par les noms mais il parlait
de son alcoolisme
ok à quel point c'est un peu c'est un
peu ce que moi j'ai vécu un trou de cul
s mais lui savait que l'alcoolisme ou au
ski
de déni total puis il les vit que risqué
avec sa pierre m'en donner il parle de
son enfance qui se rappelle tout le
temps à quel point ces 500 jours c'est
pas beaucoup la c1 en échec les rechutes
peuvent être imminente
mais il se rappelle moi je sais ça bout
là je le garde tout le temps je fais at
elle dit on se parle est à l'appui juste
avant de passer jusqu'à manquer tu sais
qu'il faut que tu écoutes par les
territoires ce qu'ils disent est ce que
tu es quelqu'un qui est comme ça tu es
un bon cas on va chercher ce côté là
c'est pas de la caméra parle laisse les
parler de ceux ci s'est constamment
jamais avant une migraine qui est le
vrai moi que de colo qui échappe aux
digital est le résultat d'une insécurité
que marx a donné une image de gallas on
parle et on finit par un plafond beach
en cpe et les gens sont abonnées
là-dessus pure mais des podcasts bonus
là dessus avec des amis tu es vraiment
de l'attendu âge puis j'ai des amis qui
lui a été alcoolique et toxicomane au
wawel alcool et pas deux a plus plus le
printemps qui est fini par la thérapie
il a fallu qu'ils touchent comme le font
pour vraiment qu'il faut que j'y aille
tout ce que tu m'as m'en excuse je peux
en présentant mes amis s'appelle cédric
e-mails et bassiste mais c'est vrai que
j'aime à se rencontrer parce que c'était
un extrémiste oui j'en passe à dire
extrême s attaque arables mémé ccc que
ça c'est des gars comme nous il ya des
gens qui sont capables pas comme cédric
puis moi sont capables d'avoir des
avertissements puis de changer sont les
avertissements moi j'en ai eu plein de
gens venus des landes dans mon show dans
la complète mais moi qui s'étire écume
les dégâts qu'il faut que les dans un
gratte le béton un tact a pas goûté
le goût de rang ne change pas mais
encore j'ai été chanceux puisqu'il y en
a qui goûte le goudron puis ce que ça
fait c'est ça te fait creuser un trou
dans lequel personne plutôt relevé
personne peut tendre une perche était
trop loin mais moi c'était ça ma femme
mon entourage ma productrice celui qui
aime à véronique c'est ma chérie d'amour
je sais moi ma meilleure amie vers une
trépanier a rappelé une fois en criant
son père tout le monde car si tu fais
estimé la même voie que la petite fille
devait pas de riz la gratte ciel dans la
moitié d'accord qui se suicident les
jeunes veulent pour avait crié son
téléphone de quoi tu parles a dit j'ai
deux têtes qui veut s'en aller encore
deux ans qu'on essaie de retrouver un
texte pour une tournée qu'il souhaitait
que j'appris que sont le matap à
dauendorf nom et qui est tout le temps
tg frapper fort physiquement mais
j'écris et puis je suis aussi l'attitude
c'était mon insécurité là on faisait
comme ma phase est tellement
courtemanche est ce qu a que quelqu'un
15 jamais pas quelque chose tu le voyais
dans un face et oui un auteur qui est
venu pour ses fans tori autant mauriste
mais écrit beaucoup le ses fans tori
il m'avait on s'était vus pas longtemps
hein on a un projet ensemble puis m'a
dit mais je suis content de voir cette
gaulois que je vais je pensais pas voir
un jour juste pourquoi il m'a dit tu te
rappelles du piment à mener une date que
jamais je comprends pas comment j'ai
oublié ça il m'a dit qu'il travaillait
pour moi pour le pour nous pour le
festival juste pour rire puis qui veut
plein blague puis que je n'avais pas
aimé la blague je commence j'avais
commencé à paniquer si je te dise
toujours dans des modes de panique ça
arrive je serai mais tous les matins je
regarde ta femme te connaissent pas ça
très grave c'est + cats panique s'est
pas comment gérer le jouer et rejouer
après les jo une après l'autre les jo
que jamais pour ça que j'ai fait ça on
sera obligé lancer de papier et lui a
capoté sélima dit simone et aurait
compté sur un mode s'est dit qu'est ce
que les autres font
je pense qu'on est les plus sous-estimés
même on écrit des tonnes de john bois
récupéré quatre gros pour avoir notre
gagne-pain la tueuse
les fronts se faire en bayard parce
qu'on n'a pas écrit à ses idées puis
j'avais écrit toute la nuit pour toi tu
t'es sûr que j'étais un des seuls qui
peut écrire quelque chose pour toi parce
que ton humour était dur à saisir vu que
c'était très physique dans le temps -
puis tu m'envoies seulement mt puis j'ai
cap je dirai pas un mot
j'écoute merci de me l'avoir dit pas ce
que je montre un autre force dans sa
bouche on fait un appel à un autre
témoignage qui fait qu'il ya des auteurs
faire attention attention c'est sûr
parce que tu penses que au québec
tellement le milieu de l'humour et est
énorme qui prend tellement de place pie
que les humoristes et des rockstars ici
l'outil est ce que tu penses que ça joue
un rôle pour m
pour ce genre de comportement pour
quelqu'un quitte à risque de se mettre
au dessus des eaux tout d'avoir d'avoir
des comportements qui qui diminue le
monde autour de quitter l'été parce que
si toi la superstar hypothèque ses
toiles c'est le monde que le monde
arrête en autobus en criant c'est rachid
badouri dit est ce que tu penses que ça
ça contribue à ce genre de comportement
ne passe que tonton témoignage à toi
c'est paul premier qu'on entend qui est
problématique dans le milieu de l'humour
et de jeu j'essaie de penser aux mots
depuis tantôt le internement c'est que
le web en français
un sentiment que tout est dû l'espèce de
l'espèce de statut que lui mourra au
québec contribue au fait que ça crée des
situations comme si c'est une très bonne
question moi je te dirais que n'importe
quelle situation
ou est-ce que le succès dépasse de
caractère en personne oui et en humour
au québec
oui moi quand je parle à des français je
leur dis comment j'ai vécu ce que j'ai
vécu c'est à dire comment j'ai une
facilité au niveau du succès comment
qu'on m'a donné tout de suite
majoritairement départ des cris des
villes
oui mais en fait quand il signe avec des
grosses compagnies production ton
premier shoot est majoritaire n'est pas
50 50 la ctu téa majorité puis mettre
l'argent pour toi mais les toits demain
lors on s'envole puis je vous aime
j'aime vos beaux yeux clairs fait rêver
ok tu sais quoi on s'en ouvrir un
restaurant c'est un bref instant juste
parce que vous avez des beaux yeux bleus
mais butait de l'entregent je vois m
sept cent mille dollars sur sur notre
entreprise
puis je dois vous mettre majoritaire
dans les ports si cela on parle des
vraies choses mais ton premier chômeurs
et ramé pièces de dette
puis on me donne un show de même qu'il
ya eu un succès phénoménal ptt ont été
majoritaires et tu trouves le moins de
chalets de plaindre ce qui arrive ça
c'est mes amis coach m'avait dit ça m
avait dit qu a le succès il m'avait dit
est une anglophone the biggest foot you
wish for et beaucoup de monde vu du
succès mais est ce que tes bobos est ce
que ton caractère est capable
d'affronter parce que le succès y attend
0 c'est un gobain pressé pis le
caractère c'était une torture qui prend
bien son temps à changer selon ce que tu
veux si ça marche pas tu es fou dessus
tu es mieux souhaité moins de succès
travaille t à faire tranquillement puis
phi phi phi tranquillement vos avec ça
ils l'être humain n'est pas conçu
krainer pour gérer autant de succès sans
que cela n'affecte sa vie personnelle
si ça affecte pas sa vie ça va affecter
son entourage qui eux vont être les
premiers mais m'a dit il ya changé at a
même pas changé et il se peut que ça
arrive c'est pas possible du jour au
lendemain dit peu plus de décréter le
nez allumé rouge du jour au lendemain tu
peux plus t'en gueuler que la fille aux
allemands parce qu'elle comprend rien
que la bouilloire que tu as acheté
marche pas mais la comprends pas que du
peuple ne peut plus faire ça tu peux
plus tu dois avoir un comportement
irréprochable mais ça va pas avec le
succès qui étaient envoyés ou ce qu'on
te donne un message francs et dur qui
dit tout est permis
oui tout est permis tu peux passer en
avant n'importe qui s'est permis pour
toi mais ces fausses et erronées
c'est vanité c'est mensongère c'est pas
vrai mais si cette image là qu'on donne
c'est pour ça qu'on pète quand le succès
redescend tu te retrouves plus on te
fait accroire honteux mis dans
l'atmosphère dans la pesanteur pendant
des années après son long terme y sont
appelés à graviter a fait ce qu'ils font
mais c'est ça que ça a fait tu as fait
un petit genou n'ont pas tenues de fête
qu'est ce qui se passe alors descendu
sur terre
c'est pour ça que le succès le plus je
peux en parler de même avec un bébé avec
un deuil de ma mère avec ma femme qui
avait menacé six fois avec ma carrière
que j'ai failli planter avec l'argent
que j'ai perdu que les niaiseries j'ai
fait avec tout ça je peux t'en parler
d'eux mêmes mais tu le vois pas si au
début mon voisin possible personne peut
comprendre son futur toute l'année ça
retombe et au ressenti à tomber ou que
tu dis que ça retombe le tu te rends
compte rien sortir de la dernière année
mais j'ai encore été chanceux j'ai gardé
mon succès j'ai jamais sorties de la
catégorie à
quand ça vient pas de moi savent et
demie booker qui me disent que je me
suis posé la question je sais basse je
sois encore en catégorie à
selon ce que le monde me demande pour te
pays dans des corbeaux privé dans les
évènements au camp convent tons chauds
oui parce que je regarde on fait des
événements corporatifs cemac watkins est
celle où tu te rends compte à quel point
on est des humains riches parce que
écoute fait une heure on paye des médias
cela sympa tabarnak comme tu le dis
qui mérite sort je peux pas dire que je
mérite ça je fais quoi moi il ya un gars
qui pioche dans rue à côté j'ai fait la
construction ses mains son magasin de
savoir prendre des années il faut qu'ils
attendent à noël pour ses vacances moi
demain demain je peux partir en vacances
je peux prendre mon cinq chevaux j'ai
loupé je peux me le permettre les
vacances que j'ai l'horaire poche mon
boss s'est fait ces pays 20000 pour
faire un corpo comme ça mais dont je
devrais je donne un chiffre comme ça il
est écrit aux aidants quel livre que je
vaux 20000 ccc dans le pti dans
l'atmosphère là c'était c'est le monde
cherche c'est si virtuelle c'est comme
une garantie prolongée commander chez
future shop le monde est menacée ou la
garantie ce n'est pas la voir arriver
quand tu arrives et perdre mais c'est ce
que ça vaut au fait que j'achète de
l'air il faisait seul client j'achète
dollars oui en fin de compte tout achat
de la grosseur parce que mais ce prix là
et virtuels et c'est tellement important
que tu sache qui est virtuel parce que
si c'est pas écrit dans un livre un
docteur un chirurgien c'est écrit dans
un livre qui va plafonner mettons à 300
mille dollars un spécialiste lui pète le
goal plus chien sur la terre un [ __ ]
de première un vrai trou de cul des
trous de cul il va quand même faire 300
milles moi si je joue avec le feu mon
chiffre est virtuel ça va descendre
qui va vouloir engager il y avait un
humoriste dans ta je n'aimerais pas son
nom qui avait été dans un corpo
complètement mais complètement intoxiqué
une pioche frappé le gars est bonne
legault qui l'a engagé devant tout le
monde
le bosc qu'il en résumant ses employés
ben tu poses de 20000 la fenêtre 5 100
piasses été chanceux propres en fac
c'est pour ça qu'il faut faire attention
c'est je m'en plains pas de salaire
qu'on fait c'est ce qu'on a décidé pour
les québécois et les québécoises au
québec c'est ce que ça vaut voilà je
parle aux français ils pensent qu'on est
des foules quand je leur dis non je fais
tél oui je vend 300 mètres bien sûr 9
millions d'habitants
on fait même pas 300 milles bien ses
chaussures 65 millions d'habitants là
bas quand je parle à mes amis new york
l' que j'ai rencontrés dans les
festivals anglais quand j'ai fait est
juste voilà ils mangent du beurre
d'arachide pendant des siècles il y en a
encore laissé d avoir un respect
regrette fruits sur internet y habitent
encore un colloque et ses amis ont fait
peut-être 70000 par année peut-être cela
dit ça fait 15 ans qu'ils fassent aussi
j'ai jamais vue de ma vie un humoriste
comme ça ils sont peut-être huit aux
états unis qui font la grosse argent
c'est en lice y regarde julien julien
lacroix commence à démarrer pour lui
c'est un moment donné il faut que ce
soit faudrait quasiment qui a une école
de tir pour la boîte à questions avec
des gens très terre-à-terre qu'on est
con à vérifier qu'on analyse et qu'on
sait qu'il ya aucune trace de
supériorité ou d'égocentrisme en eux ils
sont vraiment de la pure immunité on les
nomme comme prof c'est un cours
obligatoire sinon t'as pas ta plaque de
l'adisq n'a pas le droit d'aller aux
oliviers t'as pas le droit de vendre de
billets s'étant voleurs petit post le
court juste pour compte tattoo dante est
champion de même atteint tu te lèves
lent il ya un petit qui restent qui
passe à côté tout est clean des yeux
john sting fini faites moi de savoir que
j'avais en corse cette catégorie hall
avec tout ce que j'ai fait c'est un
miracle
comment tu veux que je pourrai
connaissant pour le reste de mes jours
c'est impossible que j'imagine qu'avec
le temps tu sais depuis neuf ans a
commencé en 2005 quand et comment ces
deux connu jusqu à havelock peut-être
quelques indicateurs vraiment liste de
règles imagine qu'avec tout ce temps là
ne brûlez des ponts l'entrée par nous
les amazighs ces faits qui ont qui on
est et ouais la beauté c'est que ça
vient mais aujourd'hui c'est seul
aujourd'hui le monsieur travaille à part
on sait qu'on ne se fait pas tout seul
parce que c'est vrai mike ward c'est le
goal plus frein le poison n'être que tu
vas rencontrer sur la terre on a même
voulu faire taire mike pour plusieurs
fois ce que voulait être
le monde voit un provocateur et voit un
gars très raide mais qu'à travers son
run et si je peux l'appeler comme ça
c'est un des hommes les plus
intelligents que j'ai rencontrés sur la
planète
c'est un gars extrêmement honteux mais
lui quand il ya vu mon changement
première fois que le nouveau en
spectacle
anecdote rapide ça c'est sa blonde qui
triple sur moi marie que je salut est
venu voir et à saint jean sur richelieu
était de nouveau à saint jean puis lui
il connaissait mon technicien jonathan
fait que tu puisses ma route et toi ça
serait cool comme enlevé dans le bon
vieux temps c'est son ancien tech puis
plus le choix
passez moi je le voyais de la scène plus
je le voyais ça prochainement bien lol à
l'intra qui viennent boire dans l'os je
l'attendais le web est content il fait
j'ai regardé tons chauds ce constat des
jo jb oui qu'est-ce qui fait qu'un bon
c'est plus
toutes ont des amis comme ça on a
commencé à sortir de nos femmes sont
devenus super amis puis on a commencé à
se parler demain pie ix a vu mon
changement frac et nous voir c'est le
moment où je commence tranquillement à
changer le rapport qui sera avec moi
j'arrive quelque part le rapport au
quinquis qui est éditeur sur mon
spectacle j'ai la chance d'avoir le
rapport qu'un sochaux c'est même lui qui
m'a proposé fax comme ta manette tout
ton changement si et sincère nature je
te parle d' exemple que je peux en train
de me vanter les gens je te parle de
témoignages cigala parle pour moi
j'entends du mic et laurent parler de
moi sos ou esprits s'apaisent ouest sous
écoute écoute n'ont pas eu un segment y
parle pendant 5 minutes du vrai rachid
de nouveaux rachid est il pas loin et
rachid et ailleurs c'est à faire puis il
ya une fille qui était avec eux qu'ils
ont assuré ces fous d'entendre ça parce
que moi j'entendais pas dit c'est puisse
parler franchement puisque comme quand
ces freins qu'en c1 quand ça vu vraiment
venu de ton coeur parce que tu veux
blessé personne peut aussi pour ta santé
mentale [ __ ] une fille aussi qui toi
tu es un coach en anglais je me suis sur
internet qu'ils disent est facile de
retraite chez neuveu arrête de taper ses
enfants c'est une réflexion que toi tes
factures auquel allaient les mêmes mots
mais quand tu le fais de bon car les
gens vont parler par elle-même on est
une communauté on est des frères et
soeurs les humoristes et même s'ils font
juste coude mais c'est la vérité ils
vont parler par eux mêmes
quand tu reçois martin petit kit envoie
un texto qui dit ton affiche c'est la
plus belle si tu veux fondre martin
petit et le micro d'argent à la micro de
feu le 6 mai qu'on argent c'est l'album
d'ailleurs savez si c'est un gars que tu
regarde jouer qui qui vu dans les
bizarroïdes dans le temps puisqu'il
temps affiché la meilleure
son affiche à elle est une seule à lui
bassin d'eau si les hawks voilà des
conversations lui moi j'avais écris tu
me fais chier quand est sorti son
affiche qui était il faisait la notation
à montréal pendant qu'on agit c'est lui
qui rentre il faudra celui qui est fait
c'est celui qui fait simple c'est lui
qui a fait le cover de coriaces aussi la
clé qui me nominer comme meilleur je
suis pas félix renault aussi un des
meilleurs mais j'écris pour faire ce
sont la fibre est douteux que j'ai écris
tu fais chier traduction du langage
jalousies et les justes rosneft on
affiche est la plus tard il m'envoie
pourquoi qu'ebola bouton afficher en
affiche est la plus belle bravo h comme
moi merci martin c'est vraiment très
apprécié blanc toi ça me touche désolé
pour le texte trop excité avec les
récréateurs lui m'a écrit à 4h métier ça
parle paru mais moi je le fais pas pour
ça mais c'est le cadeau qui me vient
avec une repentance sincère parce que
c'est ce que tu ressens des fois c'est
comme quelqu'un de ton entourage qui
justement qui te rend unique trith jupe
tous les comportements pas correct puis
à manier dit j'ai changé mais tu le
crocodile est ce que tous les gens ton
entourage qui qui qui te crois pas
sincère dans sa démarche pour la plupart
se disent qu'ils rachid vraiment changé
pour vrai
je pense que des gens qui se méfie mois
celle qui est très sensible à ce que tu
ressens
malgré que j'étais dans certains pays
bas n'excluent pas que des fois je
l'abordé language qui ne me font pas
encore confiance mais je pense qu'après
les premiers mots qu'on se parle
ils sont déjà qu'une différence j'ai le
cousin de ma femme qui lui c'est un guy
a lepage c'est une autre phase bling
mashaal pour qu'on est super ensemble
parce qu'il veut comprendre qu'est ce
qui s'est passé puis lui m'a appelé on
peut aller prendre un verre ensemble
puis le soir il m'a appelé et m'a dit
râches
je veux juste dire que je sais pas qui
je parlais tout à l'heure mais ici c'est
vraiment hâte de pouvoir parler avec
quelqu'un qui est un souci pour tous
maintenant même un intérêt pour la
culture en avance avait parlé de
louanges on sait on se reparler de tout
genre de choses je n'aurais pas été
capable de suivre ce combat parce que
j'avais pas un intérêt pour la culture
l'intérêt pour l'intérêt des gens pour
qui c'était c'était même si au final
beaucoup dans ce sens ça c'est
l'insécurité qui te fais ça faut jamais
sous-estimer ça a juste dit que c'est
quand tu dis par contre que tu as changé
la donne des exemples celle à dire mais
abbas et les actions qui attention qui
dit que change oui c'est moi je le
faisais avant dans les débutants j'ai
changé non tu t'améliores tout un
processus mais t'as pas changé dit post
quant à changer sur le début tout une
omd des témoignages cet endroit des
gardes et c'est ta fierté
mais si je changeais excuse moi je tiens
non
qu'est ce que voulez vous mais est-ce
que tu étais admettant que si ce que tu
sais maintenant
ouais est-ce que tu souhaiterais un
succès plus tempéré avec ton caractère
du temps tout se parler du succès versus
direct
est ce que maintenant tu es là tu dis
que c'est un miracle qui était encore
tout ce que tu as maintenant sachant ce
que tu sais sachant que finalement tu
perds pas de poids perdu vraiment toutes
les opportunités que tu avais tout en
beauté sachant tout c'est ce que tu
souhaiterais si tu pouvais changer
quelque chose
est-ce que tu changerais quelque chose
est ce que tu souhaites rhin succès -
instantanée et je souhaiterais
d'ailleurs non souhaités soit c'est ce
qu'est ce qui fait la force dit louis
josé houde puis de ces gars-là c'est
l'heure l'homme lors leur bûche âge way
touch a rencontré ses fans fallu non
fallu 6 go le plus terre à terre au
monde
si le gars qui était le plus encore
toutes les humoristes du québec qui a
commencé en même temps que tu le
regardes par l'ex avec sa sérénité
c'est un sage dans un corps de encore
d'un jeune homme de mon âge peut-être un
peu plus jeunes puis mais il ya vécu
tellement d'affaires que si un jour lui
ça pète pour lui et ça va péter je viens
de voir son show là au bordel j'ai fait
qu'à mon âge j'ai vu des extraits que
c'est sûr que ce goal or on va tomber en
amour avec lui ou un même titre qu'on a
tout tombe en amour pires méthodes bio
m'étonne quand tu parles à n'importe
quel humoriste de la cuvée 2004 2005
selon lui josé en descendent
ils vont tout te dire qu'ils ont croisé
plus à quelques pas à quelques pas et
ont croisé qui a drôlement à victo en
train d'animer une soirée jeux puis à
les sortir des ddd pilote pour aller
animer ses soirées loupé avec sa fille
sa femme puis samedi c'est il va t'en
parler quand qui a eu son succès sa
frappe est de même paul pierre en plus
des centre bell pour face et soirée
disco psy soir excepté moi j'en ai fait
une assez foulon et 20000 personnes en
salle je te le dise de gaulle à tout le
monde est en amour avec lui parce qu'il
ya tellement bougé
il a tellement vu c'est quoi c'est comme
quand tu vois des immigrants qui
arrivent ici à montréal petits copains
qui font pour avoir la flemme de travail
est de même de suite le jour 1 pi 2 po
l'archi puis de devenir des workaholics
ses passions vicois ailleurs ils savent
c'est quoi fake sont dans un mode armée
ou ce qui se dit je peux pas me
permettre de faire ça quand tu as vécu
la mort au canton vécu le deuil quand tu
as vécu la descente aux enfers comme
cédric c'est lorsque tu dis je peux pas
qu'il le vue c'est dommage
la vie n'est pas comme ça c'est ce côté
platement tu as le côté qu'ils font la
vie peut pas ta menant le futur peut
dire ça c'est wazza direct de quotas de
la touffe de changer ça mais non faut
que tu apprennes par toi même c'est beau
de planter il ya un proverbe qui dit le
juste ton de cette fois il se relève
si lui ai juste piller parfait puis se
relève au chic hip hop on a envie
sas être encore plus fort c'est quand
mon père mais je trouve certainement
quétaine ce qui te tue pas te rend plus
fort mais non il a raison ça te rend
encore plus fort et plus proche plus
sensibles je pense que si j'avais à
changer quelque chose
avoir su ce qui s'est passé le chef de
la changer dans le futur
je leur ai demandé où un succès moins
rapide août - gros ou aller dans une
école pendant je sais pas s'il existe
est également un pendant que je suis ce
succès là pour m'assurer que je fais
on parlait de vianney démarche innovante
et avait coûté 9 classes avec lui sans
parler de chemin et lui un parc où
comment c'est difficile puis c'est
drôlement venant ici à matin j'entendais
une entrevue à radio okapi
justement il faisait poser des questions
quand même tu es un parcours assez
longue
il commençait avec mon premier gala en
2009 2010 2 gagnants 2011 mais c'est ça
quand même été un cas tant qu'émetteur
le grand public le connaît plus avec
light moi dit encore le sait pas tout le
grand public qui connaît tous puis dit
arrête tout et il y en a qui dit je suis
content que ça se passait comme ça parce
quelqu'un qui aimait tant le monde même
chose ça me dit je suis prête et
j'aurais pas voulu paniers de suite
d'abord un show que je peux vraiment
faire acquis pas vraiment mûri piketty
fait les frais je me sens en bonne place
au bon moment au pire je comptais comme
ça mais c'est yannick c'est quelqu'un
que on l'a vu dans l'entente du dans le
podcast
s'il ya eu un succès qui explique un peu
ce que je te disais talent et à passer
par les étapes au ski et d'autres pour
d'autres personnes ça se fait pour la
santé ça se fait ça se fait juste pas me
voir aller comme gel comme la vitesse où
j'allais dans le temps où ce que je me
prenais pour quelqu'un d'autre mais
quelqu'un comme yannick qui peut voir ça
de ce que tu sais par où j'ai passé même
pour pour cracher demain corneille avait
une toune dans ma saturn que tout le
monde capoter la bourse communale parce
qu'on vient de loin
annoncée pour cet essai
[Musique]
parce que je rien à perdre du midi je
suis jaloux de vous de ceux et celles
qui prennent leur vie leur corps pour
acquis c'est parce que tu quand il
comprend d'où cornet vient de ses
chansons le sait dans quoi ils disaient
c'est je suis jaloux de ceux qui qui qui
qui qui ont de la misère à vouloir fêter
des fêtes de se retrouver à noël de
l'institut vim
c'est ce que j'ai vu ma famille ce faire
assassiner devant moi puis après ça je
sais même pas ce que je m'en allais puis
que je suis là puisque le jeu est une
vedette justin chanteur puis j'ai une
famille et puis j'ai juge alou de toi
qui prend pour acquis la vie je suis
jaloux de toi qui prends ta tombe fin
pour acquis peut-on ça me parlait mon
quand j'entendais se jeter comme mène
pas le droit de faire ça comme but pas
le droit c'est légal mais en même temps
faut que tu le vivent
mais tout ça t'arrive à 60 ans ou ce que
tu as tout perdu tout moment la maman ma
femme je pense qu'elle permettrait de
dire aujourd'hui son père un bon modèle
t il ils ont laissé qu'un mon ami que
j'ai marqué façade donc mon ma femme et
son frère lors pas les allées c'est très
très jamais abandonné parti faire sa vie
ailleurs dans un autre pays c'était
rigolo et jusqu'à aujourd'hui se
réveille pour et je demande pardon je
sais pas si c'est pas grave ça ça vaut
pas puis ça va parler à des gens pis je
mangerai que la coupure d'école mais
jusqu'à aujourd'hui on a essayé de faire
des contacts ont essayé de lui faire
comprendre que tu peux pas couper ce
lien là c'est tellement important que tu
as deux mères de pères un parti qui dans
ta famille qui doit élever
c'est trop importante peut pas le
sentiment d'abandon vois tellement
générer des problèmes des traumatismes
chez toi plutôt anti puis le voit avec
ma femme qu'est ce que ça a fait clic de
ya peut-être 70 aujourd'hui puis veut
rien savoir
c'est quand on parlait d' extrême oui il
ya le bihan xtreme legends qui vont
malheureusement peut-être à la dernière
seconde de souffle ont demandé pardon
sous leur lit de mort à l'hôpital mais
encore là pourquoi attendre jusqu'à
l'automne
tant mieux ça tu arrives là ma fille est
jeune
un deuxième enfant ma femme est
ravissante ma carrière va bien je suis
là je suis dans la sincérité que ce
nouveau show là pourquoi pas le faire
quand c'était encore chaud et des
affaires il ya des affaires qui
reviendront jamais mais pour faire le
pour retourner à ce qu'on disait un
petit peu plus tôt le je m'excuse fait
vraiment un bout de chemin
c'est maintenant ce lien là avec avec ta
femme puis son père
ça reviendra jamais une sécheuse aussi
viendront jamais probablement proche
c'est d'accord mais un je m'excuse
ça fait vraiment un match mains plus
tard une fois que la poussière est
retombée nos actes et puis mettons dans
ton cas toi toute l'époque on parlait
qui ont été brûlés 1 je m'excuse sincère
puis comme on le sent maintenant comment
on y sent toi devant nous en ce moment
de dire d'admettre d'admettre ses torts
pis faut ce record avec ce qu'on disait
par rapport aux québécois tout à l'heure
du fait que la sincérité même si c'est
pour dire je m'excuse d'avoir fait sûr
ça fait vraiment son gouffre énorme et
ça dépend juste de quoi et tu vas vite
on excuse si c'étaient des excuses comme
moi j'en fais à peine d excuse moi mais
c'était pas des excuses 500c des excuses
s'adressent sentir comme on l'a bien sûr
c'est le monde jeudi pour les mêmes paul
c'est décédées étaient des excuses de
sites appelait faute pas ma réputation
mais des excuses de j'en ai mal j'en ai
mal parce que c'est pas moi j'en ai mal
parce que j'ai je m'en veux à moi votre
raconter une histoire drôle ok on avait
un peu plus de dix mots je voulais pas
les voir le psychologue j'en parle dans
mon show c'est ma femme qui m'a demandé
absolument puis
c'est une condition oui oui une et
plusieurs autres matam ce sens n'était
puis on parle des cas que de commencer à
les voir le jeu partie le voir parce que
dans mon show je ne dis pas mon public
mais c'est pas important c'est que c'est
pas le chemin vers la guérison a
commencé beaucoup plus tôt que quand
j'en parle dans mon show même pour les
besoins du sketch ça marchait pas il ya
là trop fallu que je fasse deux je
reviens je repars je reviens je reprends
dans l'histoire que j'avais perdu tout
le monde on le fait comme ça les
premiers radars tout le monde était
perdue mais cruel ça n'est pas trop de
boue mais on comprend ce que tu t'en vas
au fait que j'ai juste coupé ces objets
dixit arrivé en même temps que ma
maladie
à 40 ans le poids de sens puisqu'il ya
quarante ans ça fait seulement deux ans
depuis mon cheminement gelé commencé et
peut-être 4,5 en dieu mais je le faisais
pas avec un thérapeute tout de suite je
le faisais avec mon ex gérant qui était
de confession pastorale ces puits lui le
le le le moi je prévois la relation dead
c'était sa vocation première avant même
sa profession fake j'en faisais beaucoup
avec lui aussi lecture aussi mais le
thérapeute thérapeute a commencé
vraiment est peut-être un an et demi
deux ans en france puis habite en face
de chez nous sont la même rue fait que
je pensais que le cnt est vraiment en
phase là j'avais acheté mes tickets de
métro qu'on s'appelle vous êtes à 200 m
comme quoi et je m'assois dans son
bureau puis la journée où je m'en vais
là je pète une crise dans la maison de
d'anxiété parce que plein de choses vont
mal je sors de chez juste pour rire puis
le processus de la quittance est
tellement tellement compliqué légalement
c'est tellement dur sur mes épaules que
je perds des ventes en france
parce que tant et aussi longtemps
légalement que j'ai pas sorti de juste
pour rire je peux pas me mettre en vente
mon spectacle en france le problème en
france c'est que tellement de roulement
force punk de bonheur ses six mois un an
la manse avant
et la façon ceux concernant les j'allais
mettre les billets se vendent en
mangeant bar-sur-seine du bois c'était
la première fois de ma vie que je
remplissais pas en france c'était
vraiment vraiment vraiment une période
de marde
ma femme voulait pas être en france à la
même pas par ici une ville qui est dur
c'est n étaient pas habitués
on avait de la misère à trouver
quelqu'un endroit pour ma fille pour
l'école mon père allait pas bien
vraiment pas bien
je commence j'ai fait une crise de
panique à maison de l'art et je commence
à sacrer mais comme si moi j'ai entendu
chaque état vie et ça et perd ça m'a
fait ma fille constat thérapie ou tu
comment chez vous non je suis chez nous
le remettre mon manteau pour aller voir
monsieur bruno ma femme est dans la
cuisine est en train de refaire une
recette de sa mère de ma fille est
partie est parti avec notre amie fatima
plus que mange fait tout petit je
commence à dire des moues de même les
mémés vraiment arrêter là un syndrome de
tourette l'amour gay de castro dkf
france dames à paris de martine wille de
cadres des rouges bleues volées puis
crée le bug des cafres et je ferme ma
foi on me regarde comme ça et pour
peaufiner encore plus parce qu'elle veut
rire à se cache en dessous du c'est
comme un passe plat d'ascq h par et je
l'entends tu entends ray comme les
salles et parce qu'il me connaît
tellement aldi fossat sortant trois mois
gerini pas me dis c'est pas normal que
pendant toute la quittance 3 10 c'était
dur on avait des lettres d'avocats cette
offre barroso a encore des traces de ma
maladie qui me faisait mal juste plus
capable vitesse cette ville d'amara
autour des poteaux des caves ou des
chiens sata puisqu'il est plus clip
scream qui n'a pas inscrit pas mais je
n'arrête pas pu jouer mon manteau que
dubai chérie c'est qu'un appui ferme la
porte puis je décembre puis dedans
russes parlent encore gagne 2,4 j'avais
une psychologue ont le plus bas à 280
ray monsieur l'arbitré monsieur et son
accent de mardi
dark side car face à bellucci que saab
en scène dans leur poche bien des caves
plus je monte en haut que je me calme je
veux pas y aller faut que je rende ma
part je m'assois que je dis mais vous
n'avez pas l'air très bien voilà parfois
c'était presse a dit me dis qu'est-ce
qui se passe j'ai bien moi je vous le
dit mr pascal habite paris du oui je
vous avais une grand mère oui mais
combien parisienne du scénario mais ça
se peut que j'ai insulté va grandement
votre père vous tous ceux qui habitent
paris j'ai insulté par les corps
arrivent mais son rythme can't et puis
dibbouk ouvriers dit parce que c'est
tellement typique ce que vous venez de
faire mes modèles nom de ce que j'ai
fait j'ai fait une jambe
faut que ça sorte sifteo dndi gants de
boxe j'arrête défonçant sable de fallait
que tout sorte notre combat puis il m'a
dit vous n'avez pas insulté ma grand
mère je vous rassure qu elles dorment en
paix dans sa tombe
ni moi ni ma mère hlima femmes
d'ailleurs vous vous êtes insulté
vous-même de deux caves c'est ça jouer
une expression québécois et de chez sal
et de put se sache durait depuis
beaucoup mon petit film bon ben ce n'est
pas ma grand mère la [ __ ]
ce n'est pas vous non plus mais vous
vous êtes insulté vous même d'avoir pris
ces décisions d'être venu quand même en
france sachant que c'était le bordel de
de vous avoir ne veut pas arrêter deux
secondes pour vous dire hello là on sort
d'une cellule et j'ai failli mourir le
gibet parti qu'est ce qu'on fait le
choix de l'os était contractuel c'est
compliqué si vous n'êtes pas arrêter
deux secondes j'avais pété bêtement je
vous fait rire mais sa base j'étais à un
psycho il faut que ça sorte qu'ils
aiment à franges et pourquoi pas arrêté
est ce parce que je l ai senti qu est ce
qui te dit j'ai senti que la pila petit
dépôt la facture moi j'ai déjà entendu
des mots tu apportes mois avec je te
donne demandé à faire c'est pas correct
en tête soit dans l'appart tu avais
besoin de libye et se voir des pauvres
piste et câlins
personnes savaient qu'ils n'avaient
aucune annonce je te laisse à aller il
m'a dit me suis cachée pour rire parce
que je voulais pour tempérer ce que la
tarière poignée de quoi l'hôtellerie et
la hâte mais il faut aussi est en train
de péter un câble c'est fou ce qu'on en
fait t'as pas manger encore aujourd'hui
non au oui le sas à rezé banker oui
serbie a commencé la discussion avec la
chute jusqu'à là je trouve je trouve que
c'est un imitateur vrai mais c'est bon
les bretons fait de bonne foi mais ouais
moi je me demande en fait si parce que
de ce que je peux me rappeler en fait
c'est pas mal le premier qui fait ce
genre de coming out le fait j'en ai j'en
ai pas entendu beaucoup d'eau mais en
fait ce qu'il valait mieux pas viennent
après
après une sortie médecin ouais sauf que
l'oeil comme couper l'herbe sous le pied
à jeu au québec qui aurait une sortie
mensuelle métier c'est y qui lisent
moins faut que j'en parle c'est ça et
beaucoup de noms qui prône maintenant
plusieurs milieux le notamment du mot
parce qu'on entend par les mêmes
problématiques comme milieu sur
plusieurs égards les j'ai l'impression
que le monde réalise pas la
problématique tant qu'il n'est pas
quelqu'un qui en est victime qui en
parle c'est souvent après que ça vient
comme tu dit c'est éventuellement pour
mac se parlaient déjà puisque ce serait
venu dans l'oreille du du grand public
pour des questions que tu puisses et
facto et synthétise la soupe chaude mais
peut-être peut-être ça va déclencher
quelque chose en fait le canadien qui
sorte qu'ils l'avouent pas tant pas de
stress on s'est demandés
mais c'est tantôt on parlait puis je
sentais comme deux volets à la au désir
de rédemption le train train de santé
que le saas parle de plus en plus d'être
plus en plus mauvaise réputation 10
herman ma carrière ça va ça va ça va
chier
pis les gens autour de toi ta femme tes
amis qui souffre aussi
je me doutais pas que la réponse mais ça
a était quoi le plus grand moteur
quelques l aspect maintenant qu'elle
volait les deux l'aider mais ma femme
jusqu'à de n'importe qui ouais
ma femme a mérité pas de témoin pas
c'est moi je la voulais je fais toujours
dans mon chose je la voulais tellement
depuis longtemps germa était premier en
huit ans le monde mais ayant grandi avec
bassel son frère ouais moi l'enjeu de la
calle avec on a six ans différence que
qu'elle vient d'avoir 21 jeunes avons 26
27 c'est lorsqu'on se fréquenter j'ai
capoté sur la jetée comme matin avec une
broche petits boutons crouch blond
fatale c'est bien comme je la veux l'au
delà qui est belle je la veux parce que
je la connais les purs et les caisses
que j'aime on a grandi qui surtout pas
qu ensemble je vous écoute les dix
épreuves concoctées jeune je voulais
sauter se découpent gelé à cause d'un
succès que monsieur pas capable de gérer
si tu l'as tu leur prends en public cela
ciel qui m'as tu vu
quand tu vu mon entrevue tout en en
pâture regarder après quand que phillip
danault il passé avec sablon j'ai écouté
le début de l'entrevue du futur la
promotion du film donne ok parfaitement
fait d'énormes on y parle de sa femme
marie qui a dit jeudi à beijing
de quoi vous parlez quand maintenant qui
est en congé pas par une paternité pied
le bébé plus belle sa tête pas du ballon
par doc est plus tout le monde part et
puis c'est normal qu'on parle de hockey
a dit moi je suis là pour le supporter
mes rêves j'ai mes ambitions c'est ce
que m'a dit c'est moi qui mangent les
cool c'est qu'un clic enquêter banshee
et puis l'autre s'est battu vicat qui
est malade cela qui rend blessé une
commotion les kits d oreille va c'est
tout
eux qui mange le coup je déteste
l'expression des retours grandhomme une
grande femme c'est comme si les femmes
étaient programm il se trouvait juste
derrière les grands
mais c'est plus derrière tout sommes une
toute terre pour grandeurs chaque homme
il ya une femme aimait pas juste
derrière est devant être le côté est
partout c'est sans elle je serais jamais
arrivé de réponse
zine el attr avère son silence à travers
le fait qu'elle a tout encaissé
adrien le fait que j'ai vu de mal que je
faisais c'est un peu narcissique est ce
que je veux dire un peu peu dégueulasse
mais il a fallu qu'ils en restent là
pour que je comprenne que ça se fait pas
c'est que quand même qu'à menace de
partir aussi qu'est ce qui te du laisser
aller parce que le type de peau je pense
que c'est pas juste de réaliser des
choses à manifoot change de comportement
ou de change
ces mets ton est ce qui était dû faire
des sacrifices au niveau ta carrière au
niveau 2 des actions au niveau de
d'habitude que ta vie pour être capables
de faire ce changement beaucoup citent
ce qu'est ce qui a aidé c'est comme si
la vie me souriait la vie moi je fais en
france du fait que j'ai pris la france
comme un criminel
qui a été qui peut plus remettre les
pieds au exactement puis qui sait quoi
je vais refaire ma vie en france parce
que mon dossier était comme sans taches
noires ans j'ai commencé de même je me
suis donné un modèle visuel moi je me
dis bon bah on va commencer là on va
commencer en france personne ne me
connaît comme étant un trou de cul si je
voyais tranquillement oui beaucoup des
cd et des roches à tous il a pas mal
pour voir pas mal ouais mais beaucoup
moins ceux souhaitant que les français
mes amis français et humoriste qui j'ai
gardé contact qui ont entendu parler de
mon sketch sur un truc qui m'ont dit
mais tu as besoin d'autant de mon trip
de mensonges pour faire du buzz
je fais maintenant c'est vraiment un
rêve et et puis me croyez pas parce que
pour eux j'ai toujours été le gars là
généraux c'est toujours resté ça ça
s'apprend pas être généreux et et
chipoter généreux
c'est juste que je suis pas des moindres
qu acheter mais les choses que je devais
laisser c'était de plus de dassier de
trouver moins de choses qui nourrissait
ma peur tu comprends on devait laisser
là parce que je t'ai dit que c'est la
pente qu'activiste puis j'avais pas une
façon dont j'avais façons très
différentes données traversy de
manifestement pas fait qu'est ce qui
nourrissait ma part ma carrière qu'est
ce qui nourrit sa marque mapanas
qu'ailleurs pourquoi n'y a plus de lait
que moi pourquoi lui et sa part comme je
pose la folle mais c'est pas juste
anormal usa prendraient une telle
critique pourquoi moi pourquoi pourquoi
pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi
pourquoi
voilà la fête a déjà pour faire ta job
c'est dur de passer du coq qui voulait
toujours être le premier la guerre c'est
toujours moi qui a des permanences à ces
choses là ça ça te dessus c'est sur
instagram même année j'étais comme un
rookie gg je suis juste choyé d'avoir
100 124 mille fans de justin
mais n'est ce pas ce que nous ferons pas
répond bien à une fille que je connais
et elle a fait des photos sexy par un
million parfait le but n'est pas d'aller
chercher des legs enfin faire avec une
agence qui sont vraiment en train de
deux mètres au visuel qu'on avait en
tête comme nouveaux concepts comme un
rat chez de plus vrai je te montrerai
après le truc c'est vraiment en noir et
blanc c'est une petite entrevue au début
parce qu'ils montrent un peu des
extraits de conférences spectacles
la fiche aussi je peux soulever vue est
vraiment comme en noir et blanc elle et
c'est moi qui joue avec ma bague de
mariage quand je parle des choses
intenses toujours entrain de ma bague
parce qu'à l'intérieur il avait fait qu
il marque et je t'aime papa sur la fiche
depuis le coeur de ma fille elle qui
conduisait maps avec le coeur qui a un
peu notre logo maintenant fait
c'est eux qui ont comme l'agent
s'appelle agence république que je
savais depuis qu'un qui m'ont fait ma
série de questions à savoir l'entonnoir
à savoir qu'est ce que je voulais pour
qu'il mette source au pape sur auto
visuellement je leur ai dit ah j'avais
pas encore enlevé cette affaire de moi
je dois j'aimerais avoir un peu de plus
de buzz puisque je veux que tu monte
monte à 2 500 1100 milles brustet commun
si je pouvais mettre le son que ça fait
dans leur tête
en fait c'était bien parti rachid tu
veux parler tu es si tu veux sauf votant
non officiellement un homme dont on veut
ressortir question dans ta tête pu faire
de ce qui est plus beau en ce moment
mais si tu n'es pas d'aller chercher des
like j'ai fait je t'aime alors certains
je sais pas toi c'est des choses qui
reviennent des fois comme satisfait même
quand il fait rire et faire rire ça
donne ce que ça donne le bleu si le
psychologue c'est monsieur bruno qui
m'avait dit après que j'avais fait ma
crise de bon il m'a dit de quoi
voulez-vous parler je sais pas j'ai
jamais fait ça mais je vais vous poser
une question quel est votre plus grand
rêve je suis gagnant nos scores dire
merci les gamins
c'est coûteux des mois plus tard il est
revenu sur sa vie avez-vous rachid à
quel point votre rêve
vous en avez fait un un boulet ça m'a
fait une épine dans votre une aiguille
dans votre boîte c'est comme cc c'est
compliqué pour toi fais ce que tu aimes
tu eu la chance de faire ce que tu aimes
les passionnés de farah merde j'ai reçu
un chèque tremplin pour qu'est ce que tu
fais comme vous faites en ce moment je
suis sur scène vous êtes passionné par
ce que vous faites la personne qui est
fort c'est pour faire ce qu'on fait leur
scène de main de ses attentes
puis en même temps quand tu vas faire ça
et je te le jure quand ils voient temps
d'entendre le moins ton à ce que tu as
tourné le coin pour le score est là ceci
si jamais ça te tente encore quand ça va
mais fais pas ça pour ça nous avons
choisi pour la récompense comme un but
récompense l'un compense on va c'est
quelque chose que tu reçois pas ce que
tu as fait de quoi mais elle voit le pas
comme une mission c est ce que est ce
que le succès ou le désert de succès
dirigé ton bateau pendant longtemps
c'est le succès pour le succès les
chiffres et non de billets l'ascension
in social énorme quand elle inculque un
jukebox une victime de ça mais c'est un
peu son jeu deviennent victimes quand un
succès banques mais des chiffres ne le
trouve pas les mots d'un billet je
progresse appelle le biais d'un oui mais
est-ce que c'est encore ce ou moins -
attends tu as raison oui ça a été chaud
au début parce que je partis quand même
quatre ans en france
quand je suis revenu j'étais à vero où
est-ce qu'on m'oublie je me pose souvent
la question trop vite l'emmène en les
rendant les jeunes surtout la garantie
dans une communauté de
gomme balloune ya peu de sucre puis on
passe à l'autre coleman est avec toi
j'ai des amis au seul régime est groupe
lacasse d'accord avis lutte m'imaginais
pas aux normes ce et 4 étoiles cavani
qui partit 12 ans j'ai l'impression
qu'elle est justement par le teddy si
petit soit afin d'en faire d'autres
ouais vous revenez la même vitesse que
tu étais venu la première fois et puis
si servi pour que yannick noah dany une
sacrée leçon m'a dit moi je veux pour
les jeux pour les enfants de de foule
puis décide c'est yannick il veut pas
sûr non j'ai juste faire son métier ses
modèles des meilleures anecdotes avec
roger mots jetés aux jumeaux parce que
j'ai avec accompagnait que ma blonde on
faisait goûter nos clope en est certain
c'est quoi les résultats ça a été
référence et moi ça à ce que vous faites
des événements privés ou juste ben on va
peut-être faire éventuellement pour
l'instant tu que l'on fait tester les
truies est encore long on a un chocolat
de boucherville le 29 octobre on fait
qu'on va être là pour vendre des plats
puis si ça marche bien on va aller à
metz avant d'investir sur une gamme de
la famille terrab parfait qui entre
yannick était le jumeau puis il passe
une que deux fois ma ration répit en
lice étaient plus mollo pour moitié le
monde avait déjà mangé puis je me suis
mis à part la limpidité tonton chaud
c'est quand la première médiatique tu le
dis à ces mots j'ai quand même un gang
cieux le pire il dit première ère
médiatique qui je voulais pas en faire
fait je vais juste pardon shopi sommes
peut-être que des médias des fois qu'ils
vont être dans ça et qui vont en parler
mais je les inviterai papa ça va me
rendre trop nerveux fake
lui il veut juste proposer son show eu
avec comme lui y est avec son humour au
sein faire la grosse offre un tour
mais ça ce sont ces son style à lui un
pisse et c'est sincère parle encore de
sincérité
moi je marche beaucoup sur la pression
ouais moi c'est un peu quand tu me
divorce à sa femme au temps de l'âge la
vente ma femme parce que a peu parlé des
éducatrices spécialisées ma femme moins
90 écoles secondaires par là des petits
gamecube dans la casquette quand tu me
parles puis je suis comme toi qui peux
quatre femmes à une mouche et cas de
parler des sujets une gamecube comme ça
lui-même dit par contre une chose que
toi tu vois on se complète à arracher du
travail souvent sur la pression ça si tu
me donnes un défi comme ça où tu me
lance là dedans on en a eu assez
d'expérience pour être capable moi ça me
dérange moins qui viennent mais je m'en
suis posé beaucoup de questions quand on
a commencé à travailler sur ce show là
j'ai dit ok c'est beau l'image du vrai
rachid ressort c'est sincère
le monde en parle par un même si
organique cette usine ce terminal
organique c'est biologique
mais est-ce qu'on va vendre des biens
sur une fan day a changé et gentil là il
n'y a pas de crise mais il boîtant
vendre des billets je faisais j'ai une
famille à faire en or et moi j'ai pas
depuis diplôme de ses jets puis je me
dis esprit trop court au sujet de mon
cours d'économie au cégep jeudi l'offre
et la demande
tableau j'ai fait excuser moi je vais
aller aux toilettes j'avais envie
d'aller jouer aux cartes en bois pvc
recyclé groupe biscuits mais mais mais
tout ça pour te dire que ça m'arrive
souvent de prendre un téléphone
d'appeler vers au besoin on a souvent dû
être vendu l'âme annonce qu on a vendu
beaucoup de billets avant la première
qui est au mois de février
ça m'a calmé mais si ce n'était pas le
cas je devrais me poser la question ça
m'avait dit on n'a pas vendu 35 mille
billets bon là vraiment la première
ce que j'aimerais capoter peut-être que
oui je te remercie pas pour moi mais
c'est plus pour les mêmes raisons sipa
pour être number one
c'est juste pour dire c'est encore cette
peur là de rédiger rien gâcher on ne
sait pas combien j'ai rien perdu encore
avec ce qui est arrivé j'ai eu la chance
d'être sur la première fois que tu fais
vraiment quelque chose le q7 exemple
2016 2015
celle où je commençais à perdre des
contrôles des affaires celle où j'ai
arrêté mon deuxième chose c'est
l'australie m'exiler 1 pour la deuxième
fois en france avec je sais pas ce qui
va arriver à ce qui est ce que les gens
vont venir ski mais je te dis l'heure
vous fait ce métier-là vos clients c'est
le public qui regarde les viewers nous
c'est live dans une dans une salle il ya
rien de plus valorisant que les ententes
de leur bouche à tes oreilles dire
qu'est ce qu'ils ont pensé toit plat
critique commis dix années qui viennent
bien bosser sur ça peut ternir mais j'ai
déjà vu des critiques se faire défoncer
des humoristes faire défoncer pu gagner
300 m
vendu à pratiquer mais les gens quand
ils sortent quand tu sors du shopi
il était en fait longtemps que tu
atteins je cherche à chaque fois choisi
louis franchement beaucoup divorce est
là il va t'arriver a mené de deux de
dire qu' il y en a un qui est venu voir
avec la salle je le salue joue pas dire
son nom
je m'en rappelle encore ce maudit je vis
ta période psychologue
puis j'ai vu sa femme en arrière
peut-être à deux mètres il ya comme
laisser un espace pour paul humilie pour
les samedis qu'est-ce qui a bâti mais je
l'avais fait seulement en voulant t elle
le vit en ce moment chez les jumeaux pas
trop de détails mais j'ai l'impression
qu'il ya donné un ultimatum et caveaux
restait alors à une femme extraordinaire
en plus tout à fait faire un beau petit
couple pas dit je vis sur la sellette
offre moins mal mais après ça chez les
mets de côté et enlevé sa chemise karaté
puis est allé voir le dr pedro malassis
à m'approprier king lopy ce ma femme la
mère de la traite comme de la main puis
il c'est ma deuxième fois ils ont pu
est-ce que tu t'entends mais que la
personne chez toi le droit de choisir
une personne moi ça a été un coup de
foudre mais ma femme est partie voir
pyschologue pas à votre ip le trouvais
qu'il s'endormait là tu es dedans et je
l aime bien c'est juste - forme un
groupe de savoir que l'or en écoutant
une musique est ici dit ah je vois
continuer à y aller
ça a peut-être trouvé des coupes le mec
c'est à peine si c'est quoi notre job en
ligne des conversations comme ça on s'en
rend pas compte oui c'est le fun le but
premier c'est de divertir on s'entend on
n'est pas des câbles on se prend pas
pour des fous robin des bois mais il ya
un deuxième volet à ce qui est de
toucher des gens et du monde qui nous
écoutent en ce moment puis qu'ils font
quand même ça ça me touche peut pas
vivre dans cette planète la rd humain
riche conduit des belles voitures face
qu'on veut comme voix hier puis mourir
comme ça c'est pas possible il faut
faire un impact si guérite heures à 16
heures est capable de faire et qu est ce
qu a fait qu'est-ce qu'on me faut pas
faut pas non plus arriver sur le shopi
de venise ddd twitter ou des gars qui
font des conversations tête heurter
l'opinion mais à travers tes blagues
thème en assumant que son skate du
suicide non j'espère qu'il fait encore
je pense qu'il a arrêté de le faire
[ __ ] il voir au festival captain
[Musique]
encore captain rigole les sexes et les
galions festival avec adib la scam
capitaine superbe leurs affiches
bref
il y jouait le jeu tu aller le voir je
vais juste après rosalie vaillancourt
puis il parle d'un sketch où est ce qui
se dit la tille la période de ce que
vous pensez que je vous envoyez des
finger parce que je m'en foutais budget
2010 à moi je connais un peu la vraie
histoire peuvent en terre là dessus pour
des raisons évidentes mais mais mais qu
ils vivaient des choses puisqu'il a
raconté sur scène et vivaient des choses
il se faisant envoyer des photos du
petit chérubin sur sa porte et arracher
la faute au bilan mais matins se lèvent
encore la photo du monde qui le menace
de mort qui menace son gérant qui menace
sa famille mexes d'un bon gauche voulait
dit c'est un bon jack la cia au fus topo
a dit qu'avec une grosse dépression
grave passer une journée dans son bain
mais le suicide il ya passé plus qu'une
fois puis on y parle qui parle de sa
live et je parle de trou de cul on
s'entend la melli parle de suicide sur
scène puis dit qu'après sa femme est
appelée marais puis je vais me suicider
ou latex pays répondent comme chercher
des capsules de nespresso parce que
marie m'en reste plus l'effet matin vers
9 suivi trente ans qu'on est ensemble
moi je me suis même pas de captieux du
qashqaï capote de ma crise que j'ai
faite d'or le cav cave câble il a réuni
pour son texte aux playes atteint par
ivo des bulles voka commence à écrire
pas dit oui je comprends va me chercher
et m'a taclé il se lève du bec samus la
fao notre présence ici d après l appel
et appel
foot - quand le petit nom panique pas
tellement cute a dit parce que gilles us
à l'égout couler l affaire pendante
m'envoyer ces objets mais pourquoi faire
tout est écrit ramène alors oui rappelé
à l'ordre m nl 1 dans une affaire où
est-ce qu'ils vont oublier ça parce que
tu étais dernière lendemain et en
nouvelle écosse moi je trouve sa
longueur pour petit j'ai fait comme
facteurs liés à trouver certains le
monder rizki trouvé tellement cute de sa
part mais elle savait pas quoi faire un
caddie au marché des capsules de fumer
un peu mais un gars comme seul il sort
un sketch demande à qui ça pense que le
monde qui viennent voir ce show leur
apport la petite gang du bureau les
profs qui sont mus des foules ils sont
donc acheté un billet pour aller voir ma
je te dirais qu'à peu près 1 20% à la
salle que eux c'est leur thérapie venez
boire du monde sait ça leur thérapie moi
j'ai une femme qui aime médical a pointé
dans l'aude à québec à la pointe et dans
le journal de québec
un show piste est le choc à les voir
avant de se suicider ça tombe extel m'y
arrête ton cinéma
madame de 65 ans belle demoiselle
beldame beaucoup de classe ah mais moi
mon show à la salle est de susciter dans
sa main ben est sauté en bas du pont le
pont de québec
ouais on m'appelle après le show guillon
mais moi dans la loge mon montech midi
une femme qui viendront mais elle a
l'air un peu bizarre je vais
t'accompagner jockey je m'assois leucan
qui est posée sur un bon et houssen ans
albert rousseau de personnes mais juste
mobile puis montguillon puis elle me dit
merci pour le spectacle est une dame
d'un certain âge qui parle avec lui a
dit merci pour le spectacle a dit vous
voyez ça a joué at il prôné là mais je
prends la lettre lui a dit ça ces
mallettes de suscite pas la reprendre
mes mains par à déchiffrer
je vous jure que j'exagère 0 lé jeu bon
exagéré mais ça c'est 0-0 puis ça va
puis il a même dit c'est une belle
histoire
hamdi hamdouchi une maladie incurable
depuis la jeunesse depuis le jeune âge
je ne peux plus supporter la douleur il
put rien qu'on peut faire pour moi j'ai
attendu que mes petits enfants soit
assez grand pour que j'aille profiter on
peut jamais profiter au maximum de ses
petits-enfants mais jusqu'à un certain
temps pour m'enlever la vie je me suis
je sais qu'ils vont être collègues j'ai
vu mes petits enfants et aujourd'hui
j'allais me suicider m'a dit quand j'ai
entendu que vous avez parlé de votre
mère n'était pas encore décédé moment
qui passe à travers 8 15 heures puis qui
s'est dit je ne peux pas quitter ce
monde parce que j'ai une famille qui
m'attend puisqu'elle passe à 310 ch qui
- chikhi moins que mes douleurs pour
faire ce geste là quand tu marques tu
liberté de leurs messes la souffrance
que tu laisses derrière toi quand tu lui
faut les comprendre les gens qui se
suicident mais en même temps faut
comprendre aussi que
les autres mais aussi dans le deuil dans
la confusion de ces sites c'est pas bon
impôt ni pour l'autre latine
puis elle m'a dit je vous remercie à la
presse à cannes à s'élever avec une
posture de femmes de qui fait du ballet
à la marche et je suis voulez vous qu'on
vous accompagne dit non merci monsieur
je suis une femme fière parties les
fêtes comme d'un pouvoir
pictures est un trou de cues d'un
pouvoir même on envoie les gens ils vont
voir si je fous là c'est le gars qui
sauvent manque à chaque à chaque fois
leur ont fait son choix chaque année là
aller à l'école mais qui fait le mec le
magnifique je pense que rendu à la
dixième édition la même qu'ici c'est un
fan de mecs là lance un fan de moins que
l'on puisse vraiment ceux des sous pour
l'aider pour messi si c'est ça c'est des
fans qui eux aller voir des choses comme
cela ça les a mais on dirait que une
fois que sur mes transperce en
perspective ce billet le le biais de
cette madame là on dirait que ça vaut
plus que trois cent mille billets
oui oui c'est ce qu'est ce qu'ils ont
eux mêmes ce qu'ils font à 15h20 c'est
de travailler chaque matin en pensant
ouais mais dès que tu as un trou dans
tes chaussettes dx dès qu'il pleut des
queues de quoi il ya de quoi qui fait
quand tu es un artiste plutôt du succès
que ça vous oubliez vite là mais on
essaie plus facile plus facile
cholly de st gall je m'en rappelle pas
que tu oublie vite la mémoire est une
faculté qui oublie c'est tellement
triste
cet oubli t'oublies ça tu te sens comme
un superman en attendant leur jetant
parata femmes sur leur ai dit vous
pleuré ensemble pour cette madame là
j'ai même pris pour elle que j'ai fait
avoir dans sa famille grassa arrête ton
cinéma on a réussi à s'était pas juste
un choix de superficialité le ceram en
parle ou du monde parce qu'une partie de
ma mère puis bang
deux jours après tout en match aller
mais c'est beau puis aujourd'hui mme et
on s'est entendus
communal collectif ça reste toujours ce
petit votre jour de battre un peu qu on
se tait eu l'impression d'être arrivé à
destination notre transformation haute
et à quel pourcentage du ratio est plus
propice ou non les gens commencent à
perdre un peu leur jeu ils prennent ce
qu'ils leur profession c'est une pilule
que tu avales chaque jour pendant trois
mois
tes cheveux arrête de pousser puis six
mois plus tard c'était chanceux arrête
de tomber d'ici mois plus tard il
commence à pousser tranquillement que
c'est à vie derrière le bois de
profession c'est mon ami qui me le
faites lire c'est écrit que si tu
arrêtes trois mois plus tard même si ça
fait 22 ans que tu apprends merci
bonsoir toujours la même envie de
toujours pas c'est que tu as eu un choc
nerveux parce que tous les chevaux vont
tomber tout et même ceux qui n'étaient
pas supposés de tomber puissions rester
solide pendant la coupe david flac tu
vas faire monsieur cuvette la fecq
c'est quoi ton propulseur toi mais c'est
ça le propecia à moi c'est le sabot de
tout à l'heure le constance a beau de
voir ce que tu peux perdre mais il n'y a
pas de destination finale vont mourir un
parfait
c'est ce qui est parfait mais en même
temps tu veux garder un certain age de
te le rappeler tu veux pas revendre
guérison totale existe pas puis deux
serais-tu plate un gars parfait ou une
femme parfaite ça serait la perfection
c'est vraiment dans l'imperfection et
mémé c'est ça mon peuple et chaussées
mons a beau c'est de savoir que tu peux
perdre ça et j'ai déjà fait une crise à
m'emmener dans ma fille est encore très
jeune
puis me rappelle l'afa ce que j'ai fait
je les sauver une fois mais ma fille est
plus intelligente que moi puis plus
drôle que moi je te dis avant tout à
votre toute la ville québec en mauricie
c'est la folle mais je les fait une fois
que je peux plus faire deuxième fois
j'ai fait mais t'as juste là j'ai fait
un jardin
puis elle m'a fait une phase de la dira
peut-être aujourd'hui
or fait ce scrutin car j'adore que
j'élimine elle est aujourd'hui bien sûr
depuis le droit ça c'est fort ce que
c'est bien de dire là parce que j'ai dit
à ma femme un certain tout le monde en
parle
j'ai dit ça y est ça y est c'est fait
beaucoup ouais mais j'ai bien précisé
oui je pas parfait j'ai dit que je
prends des sachets de sucre me décrété
d'emblée jamais en sachet après j'ai dit
que si mme kosotto recherche la trêve
c'est sûr touche à ma fille je te tue
sauf qu'il va en prison c'est ce que je
dis c'est que ça m'a mené le mot ce
parce que dans le fond c'était juste un
spot publicitaire provence on joue on
monte on écrit sur le monde est habitué
du monde qu'on écrit son beau projet des
commentaires on avait sûrement même des
mauvais des fois mais il ya quelqu'un
qui écrit ce site est un publicitaire
non c'est pas un stade c'est juste que
les media sales et frappe c'est là
dessus qu'ils veulent parler mais je
leur ai dit qu'ils appelleront du cash
dans son bras de l'homophobie où je
parle de la xénophobie où je parle de ma
femme qui est enceinte mon bébé commun
mais ça les intéresse de savoir c'est un
soutien scoops autour de savoir de ce
fait comme une autre on n'en parle pas
que c'est sûr et certain que ça
intéresse c'est tant mieux
je veux arrêter d'en parler à m'emmener
la prétendue 3 podcast on va renverser
dans aurait pu en parler c'est sûr et
certain ça me fait plaisir d'en parler
là c'est frais encore mais je vois
tomber c'est sûr il va tomber mais si le
même patin d'un truc qui revient ça
c'est pas cool ça voudra dire que j'ai
pas été fair puis seule la vie nous dira
mais pour l'instant je peux t'assurer
que nous puissions pour autant la salle
mama véronique la moa moe à moi
féliciter parce que y'a des gars hors
d'elle on arrive l'oeil à un mur blanc
puis mon nouveau décor là c'est ya rien
j'ai vu un design séries sur netflix
j'ai capoté
ma visite roaring pense que vous lui
seul
y a capoté il a déconné exit en arrière
sont les pires garde le show est un peu
trop pour moi mais j'ai pris son son
concept de dieu sait quoi vide on est
allé faire des recherches sur internet
et beaucoup de pièces de théâtre sont
comme ça en ce moment le plein plein
plein de trucs quitterait la la human
steps le haut tout ce qu'ils veulent
faire quelque chose très industrielle
mais il veut le voir les tuyaux les
vieux murs à l'olympia ont fait en
première la beauce avait dit que la
thématique de se mettre à nu aussi
exactement ça va avec comme je te dis en
dix ans je voulais pas trop c'est trop
sec les pas de lumière et rien juste un
full aux spots bon joueur quand même un
certain cachet mais j'en enlève tout
dépend de lyon j'arrive avec la salle
qui est un beau mur c'est un des murs ou
ce qui a le plus de jcall à tout
maintenant parce qu'on reçoit
c'est un oiseau qui cache à la rd9 au
concert avec les des tuyaux qui passe et
j'arrive le pied une toile de cinéma
couvre tout le monde 40 pieds par 40
pire à part ça explique m le chef coin
dans la zone dont j'avais dit de technal
de vue technique je me suis mise il faut
qu'on enlève sa patrie non pas parce
qu'on prend pas je viens de faire tout
le monde en parle
je viens de dire que c'est un nouveau
concept si si je peux pas reculé mais
des rideaux l'âge ils ont par avance à
samara pas déranger mais là non on ne
peut pas on peut pas ne peut pas non
plus le doute senti un peu la panique
s'en vient logiquement cette sud et
certaines techniques comme la donne
était projeté comme regarde ta force
c'est ton sourire chez knie dans ma
femme depuis j'aimerais moi j'avais
dents croches avant tard tout le moins
la 2 2 2 une journée sans pas sa sueur
dentaire en famille femme avait dans des
atmosphères excédant le dédain qui
préparation au daaka maudit prend soin
des dents savaton plus beaux atouts chez
les femmes on regarde beaucoup ce qui là
que ça beaucoup de fans femmes ce qui
est mon corps
70% de mes fans cd et les femmes et on
dit à 10 soit davantage à l'effort d'une
veine de l'intimidant droite existe un
beau sourire j'ai dit quand tu es gentil
des gens 6 et prince ont comme à tous
enfin que ça commence à monter salle
appelée verrou pas loin en achetant
grignon je m'en réjouis a reçu jeudi au
monaco a cité ceux assis son jeu peut
m'emmener leur parler je m'en occupe
plus je m'envoie je raccroche plus je
regarde je regarde le plafond et là je
vois un rack qui descend fait le suis
pas
on essaie de quoi je te fais un papier
que si ça marche pas plus je déchire ton
écran c'est moi qui te le pays je le
paye live qu'est mon à trois jours
d'âpres des pré prod ici avec sa marche
pas pour ce soir mon show en masse à
manger quand même pas pour la pré prod
j'ai besoin de ta salle au complet des
saints le rac
on met le lecteur sur le rac on le
montre que mapon le roll on roll on le
monte on a fait des jo qui ici qui
fument des joints tous les jours des
rumeurs viennent en masse que tu as dû
rouler un gros buy american way je viens
tu as un plan l'autre et on y est on y
est pas la fin j'ai fait une photo sur
instagram j'ai fait voici la dream team
qui sont prêts à tout faire pour que ton
style soit magnifique puis j'ai pris
tout leur hâte qui leur fait ça je sais
pas au t2 le moment les textes et ont
piqué même gêné sa photo et voilà
désormais la baïonnette voulais pas me
dit voilà qu'elle m'a forcé fait que
j'ai fait comme c'est quoi je vais les
remercier je veux le rester gentil puis
sérieusement ils m'ont même réécrit sur
un an on dit merci de pas avoir capoté
parce que ça s'enlève pas ses nombreux
monts mais moi je pouvais juste pas mon
décor fait en sorte qu' il faut qu'on
voie les les murs au complet avec la
photo que j'ai pris avec eux j'ai fait
comme merci la game and c'est vraiment
cool mais ce n'est tap
est ce que dans deux semaines il va
avoir un même problème peut-être que le
même jour une crevaison puis mais sans
égal avec ma femme but avait de quoi
puisque veut pas pu être moins tu
comprends moins un point patients mais
si ça arrive
faut juste que tu tu n'as pas ta parle
vite fait comme air
revient sur titres qui parlent d'un
moment tout peut s'inscrire avec ça peut
passer juste avant qu'on commence à
tourner on parlait de george clooney
oui puis on s'est dit on en reparle
aussi podcast je pense ça fait deux ans
et quand on compare mes mots si j'avais
entendu des histoires et on s'en parle
été décaissés goeller mettons à fin de
journée de tournage que du riz 14h15 il
ya des gars holyfield jose avec la plus
grande célébrité ça déplacé ouais mais
souvient du nom du monde et jose avec
les autres membres à longchamp c'est
incroyable puis une inspiration tc de
vie plus que ce mot n'a plus rien de mal
t'es pas habitué à faire ça à ton
meilleur et demain l'afrique et aux
humains qui est commise en anglais le
2-2 face en blanc monnaie ça va devenir
une deuxième nature pour toi qui n'es en
ramassant des bouteilles de plastique
les manants du recyclage personnes c'est
un exercice que tu fais maintenant une
bonne cause moi je vais faire ça avec
1000 avec ma fille maintenant maintenant
si ça doit vraiment c'est des fois mais
moi avec des affaires dégueulasse c'est
ça c'est quelque chose qui s'apprend
c'est du civisme ça s'apprend et des
gros mots j'ai déjà pris des cours après
ces histoires là j'ai pris un cours sur
éthique et protocoles mousse trois
machines comme souvent en claquer une
vraie claque sur le revers de la main je
marche comme une vache enragée a pris
enfin mayonnaise pas tout en vrai je me
suis fait texter pendant l'émission live
mes amis m'ont dit jtag homme singe men
affreux affreux arrête ce n'est pas pour
moi j'ai même pris des cours à savoir
quelle fourchette voire quatre
maintenant il ya un protocole tu vaux
maroc s'est invitée par la famille
royale mais tombe jamais été préparée -
mais mettons-les ministre de la culture
il s'est vu que c'est un pays avec une
monarchie absolue mais c'est très cinq
services et/ou foot sache comment par
les milieux d'affaires que tu apprends
mais ça s'apprend de s'intéresser aux
gens c'est ça s'apprend puis j'ai
toujours été un gosse généreux fac c'est
sûr que je voyais mes sauts pour parce
que je peux tu as dit koch que je
l'étais poitiers thomas qui s'appelle
faivre ingrid jacquemod au studio mel's
à tout le monde et c'est là c'est des
550 employés là bas chaque vendredi du
tournage de x-men pendant deux mois j'ai
acheté un billet de loto pour tout le
monde chaque vendredi
celui qui gangrène ce que c'est c'est 1
200 300 pièces que tu achètes même si
une pièce lâche est là c'est 150 160
pièces que tu payes à chaque fois george
clooney à ses 45 ans je pense 40 ans et
invité ses meilleurs proches le cedis
bord ibori dans un hangar d'avions
privés avec un mur roulant puis on fait
venir un traiteur puis manger et manger
puis l'homme en ayant accès vip commando
jouit notre colère a publié un avion qui
pour qui la femme en italie pour revenir
demain yep faut qu'ils se lèvent jones
et apparemment je sais pas si c'est une
vraie histoire
moi j'aime croire que les vols puis
roubles acrosport d'abord puis à 10
les gones cas faute et puis c'était un
enfant pas loin du nevada la facture
tifa le sexy 6 la route 66 son parti s'y
promener chacun sa harley factice fait
comme wah wah wah oui c'est si si c'est
la reconnaissance le quitte il de
cadeaux et ibo meetic à quand des moyens
comme lui ce point grosse à fond
le temps est un beau geste de la tension
mais d'aller le faire le tour de moto a
oui avec une amie à moi qu'il nous voir
à la salle se faisaient second que j'ai
42 ans pour moi un mac leur 42e l'info
jeudi j'avais 15 ans 7000 la salut est
venu à mon choix à la salle puis se
faisait 25 ans je l'avais pas vu samedi
des pros changé il était toujours un peu
familial toujours pareil dit pas ce que
je ferais je voulais un métis et des
lignes
cette trace oui ont paradé tu fais des
lignes et
et c'est rapidement
ok ça qu'on propose c'est vraiment foutu
mon sens faisait parler je suis un peu
dépassé il ya un exemple un contre
exemple je postais entendit un audio qui
est liquide ses succès sur le sida mais
celle que c'est vrai et un stand c'est
vrai c'est vrai il fait une défi qu il
faut voir ça juste cette semaine
joaquin phoenix sur le site de joker
mais aussi c'est aussi bas il pète
vraiment une coche que kristen bell le
faire mais lui il est plus comme titre
d'exemple j'ai occupé il dit juriste on
fait comment may take some time le genre
tu vois que c'est quand même qui
m'attaquent dans mon nom mais je sais
pas qu'est ce qui a fait ce que je
m'interroge je sais pas qu'est ce qui a
fait mais ça je le crois par contre
parce qu'elle ferait trop cool
il y en a un qui s'est suicidé alors j'y
vais là c'est une des meilleures fins
que j'ai ça dans ta vie c'est ouais
c'est la fin c'est pas un film sur les
super-héros s'imprime sur la maladie
mentale
puis dernièrement dans ma ville je vais
vraiment pas entrer dans les détails
parce que c'est trop personnel pour seul
mais il ya une personne dans mon
entourage éloignées qui rentrent en
psychiatrie dernièrement
puis tu écoutes le film puis tu dit
aussi qu'on est chanceux d'être dans un
système qui abandonne pas c'est qu'il ya
encore du travail à faire au niveau du
soutien entier pour pour les gens
démunis pour les gens qui ont des
troubles mentaux il ya encore beaucoup
de travail mais au québec on n'abandonne
pas si j'en laisse systématiquement puis
le tue vous allez voir c'est sûr seul
c'est sûr c'est sûr quelqu'un qui a une
maladie mentale qui est au courant mais
qui ce fait abandonné par par tout le
monde la société au complet le conte et
chanson
tabarnak de pas être à gotham
parce que parce que justement cette
personne là que je perds mon entourage
si on est dans une société comme ce
genre de personne c'est le fun qui a un
message comme ça dans ce film là c'est
même pas rien à voir ça n'a rien à voir
sa vie d'enfant commun s'est rendu
jusqu'à s qui parle parce que dans mon
manager jusqu'à date j'ai pas vu mais
non mr jack pour moi c est ce qu il
parle on sait ce qu'est nouvelle
nouvelle
on est dans le char est ma blonde et moi
qui convenait petit c'était c'était
lourd parce que pour vraie fête dans la
minute 1 1
t'es pas bien l'ami le ton du film
psycho envie de pleurer pendant jusqu'à
temps que ça semble vraiment que le ça
tombe un peu plus dans le joker qu'on
connaît vraiment le mais comme les
premiers 5/6 du film le temps de pleurer
pendant tout le film
puis comme pour détendre l'atmosphère
j'ai commise à ma blonde m'a dit qu'on
n'aura pas su comment qui a eu
l'escadrille est-ce que tu voyais jeune
joker dans tous vos jeunes tous que
qu'est-ce qu'il a dû recruter le voyons
noms commencent ça commence il ya déjà
depuis c'est comme dans le fond c'est un
genre de ce genre de deux semaines où
est-ce que sa firme j'ai une question
pour toi je sens voulu raconter les
détails ça t'affecte dans dans quel sens
le ton ami et ben en fait en fait je
prends une parce que cet exemple je veux
vraiment pas en parler parce que sinon
ça n'a aucun problème je vais prendre un
autre exemple que le dans le film une
des raisons pourquoi il est tellement
mimi dans la marge de l'enquêté c'est
parce qu'il ya un tic de rire fait qui
se met à rire de façon frénétique pilote
quand tout le monde le regarde qui lui
dit comme c'est quoi c'est quoi ton
problème il
une carte sur la carte ses marques et
excusez mon rire j'ai une condition puis
la carte se marquer s'est créé par ça
peut être pourrait être le retour est en
tout cas monsieur qui s'est expliqué
avec sa carte qui donne la carte les
gens comprennent
puis mon neveu le syndrome de la
tourette
puis dernièrement comme à l'école il
tend la file d'attenté pour raconter ses
envies pleurer dans étant files
d'attentes pour rentrer de la récréation
c'est le petit que le plus gentil le
petit gueule plus gentille que toutes
les bonnes intentions du monde c'est
tout le temps plus ils enfilent autant
plus quand c'est avoir des tics
langagiers la tour le la timone la
lionne faire une amende lui aussi tourné
une petite fille va te faire des bruits
priait dit je fais pas exprès pour faire
ces bruits le plat alors à le regarder a
dit je te crois pas vraiment heureux
puis lui gang est revenue chez eux et
être démolis type le répit puis moins
comme ça ça notre réseau néanmoins
passer pour ce que ce film tellement il
y en est conscient t il conscient de son
problème
sauf que ça change pas la façon que les
gens le regardent lui puis non plus je
trouve que c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
un film qui résout les parents - mais
c'est un film qui va je crois que tout
le monde devrait aller voir pour au
moins avoir c'est le le gars qui crient
dans le métro à montréal
c'est le monsieur qui crient dans le
métro le mieux tout le monde se tasse de
banques qui le regarde pas ce monsieur
le in et avec des parents il ya sûrement
des frères et soeurs il ya été élevé
probablement dans un an dans une famille
qu alice mans plus rough que tout a pu -
quitté il ya du monde qui l'ont aimée ya
du monde qui l'ont dit mais parce qu'ils
marchent pas bien meilleure image d'elle
que nous exact un gars qui marchait dans
la rue
on veut prendre montréal j'étais avec ma
fille ma femme il ya une semaine
d'actions on marche on pousse la
poussette
je ne vous souhaite encore pour les
faits de 50 ce qui est presque deux fois
puis on marche pied il ya un gothique
remake chef de l'olp
c'était très biblique monsieur le préfet
un prophète
je pense que notre origine west indies
l'été noir puis et criait puis le monde
ce temps simplement de rentrer dans les
banques
il disait rien de vulgaire c'était
vraiment comme gaulliste copie comme tu
es puis marche puis s'en vient
d'ailleurs de nous puis mafia lauper
puis ma femme et moi on se regarde on a
eu la même pensée je me suis retourné
vers lui j'étais peut-être je manger une
volée mais j'ai jamais faite parce que
j'ai toujours été
malheureusement le gore n'a pas toujours
j'ai souvent été le gars qui écrit je me
la réaction la réaction de tout le monde
qu'on n'a pas souvent voient déjà comme
souvent apprécié que j'ai déjà été
donnée de la bouffe phénomène est
souvent cité tellement un gros de notre
pensée
puis marche en arrière de nous je me
suis retourné il ya quelques passages du
film public que j'ai vu quelques
passages où je connais jean jean
baptiste jean baptiste dans la bible
c'est ce qu'il faisait il criait fort
stade job c'était d'annoncer la venue de
jésus son cousin c'est sur ce qu'il
faisait il est dans le désert pour pas
déranger le monde puis cris à manger du
miel s'habille avec des affaires de
dépôt de vache lopy si justes mais qui
parfois de l'eau jusqu'à temps que jésus
a ri puis disparaissent c'était ça c'est
comme une première partie opening au
bras puis je me suis retourné vers lui
puis 10 puis commence à crier puis tard
à côté de moi le psg demande pas de
jésus comme mon frère
puis j'ai dit c'est ça qui me fait
penser aussi aux dates puis parce que
j'allais peut dire un attardé
je comprends jeudi john baptist fait une
audience bâti
l'agrément mais mais on commence à
parler sur à peu près deux coins de rue
avant d'arriver au métro puis arrêtez de
parler je dis pas qu'à part est écrit
j'ai eu une conversation avec quelqu'un
qui était content id assurément pas bien
mentalement je pense qu'il ya quelque
chose qui marche pas mais j'ai eu une
conversation avec lui c'est normal ça
m'a ça m'a vraiment fait du bien parce
que j'étais quand même on a tellement
passer à côté de ces gens là tout le
temps c'est vrai qu'est ce que tu dis si
je conduis avec un humoriste des états
unis est à peu près 65 ans c'est une
vedette des vedettes aux états unis mais
peut-être une heure les gens parmi les
zartistes pas fait vraiment il pas été
très populaire mais tous les humoristes
l'udc aurait préféré de l'humoriste
préfère exactement ma quale d'une voix
pendant qu'on faisait d'être nick choi
qui est vraiment bon puis je les
emmenais manger une place en restaurant
pourront rouler la nuit j'ai tourné le
coin sur un banc du parc
j'ai fait y croise une fille qui était
dangereux comme ça on sort le soir
l'attaquant manceau était comme ça c'est
comme ça que j'ai arrêté je vois la page
et est-ce que ça va pas répondre pour
apprendre pop tranquillement à c'est
assez peu le monde arrêté 6 passes et
elle coûtera 3 puis est parti jean puis
l'agresseur tourné à côté de moi le
numéro respimat 10 mai mais dès 17h50
dans le même sens et la fille d'un papa
j'ai pas partout dans la soirée j'avais
juste d'intègre chacun mais c'est vrai
moi je suis papa mais j'ai vu tekin le
film n'a pas d'enfant je les ai vus en
france
je les ai vus je veux à quel bon film
d'action à ma fille qu'elle a eue deux
ans je partis en france
il joua télé je les regardais la même
façon j'ai fermé trois fois tv psg fait
j'avais ma femme les réveiller un
suédois de son nez le csp adore chez moi
peut-être car sp pau mets ton doigt le
stade l'adca secteur textile bosphorus à
dubaï les parties quoi c'est pas
vraiment faire voler enfin 10
même chose pour la prostituée qui croise
même à fond et échapper à mener par
pense vraiment explosé le même en disant
je veux devenir un rebelle se situe voix
des sans abri jamais ta vie tu rappelles
la rumeur d'hugo qui était sûr toujours
au coin de christine qui avait une
grosse barbe il y avait des sacs dans
ces pays la rumeur voulait que c'est un
neuro chirurgie qui a vraiment mal viré
la rame en alcoolisme gambling sa
famille audi garde-fous qui sort de la
maison il le monde aimait dire des
légendes urbaines peut-être ces pauvres
mecs que ça pour elle la meilleure
viande qui y ont des vies bas normand
n'est qu'un squelette ça pète moi ça
pétille du monde qui m'ont entouré qui
m'ont attrapé ouais mais s'il y avait eu
personne mais tombait donc tu continues
à ce club pendant deux ans
bousculés les liens commencé à
s'effriter camp sonel paraître sont plus
du tout personne
j'avais j'avais un cancer autour de mon
nom personnel est très motivé là toute
la gagne on prend pas de risque on
commence tout fait partie d'un
programmateur de télé ou est ce que tu
es en train de perdre à une vitesse
fulgurante le monde pour le web - fini
lorsque tu fais ce que tu risques en
moyenne d'âge 67 ans là tu fais quoi tu
prends tu indiques haye qui va commencer
de péter une crise même si du temps
ben non on va aller voir quelqu'un
d'autre qui ait autant de talent mais
qui nous fera pas de crise en train de
tout perdre la télé en somme et cherche
des concepts la mesure à paunat l'heure
le il se réveille sur le on va mettre
plus de multiculturalisme un bleu plus
de gueule à la télé et +22 de comprendre
pourquoi parce que ion sont rendu compte
que ça reflétait pas notre société mais
quand tu vois sur le web
tu peux trouver toute la lecture est
complet normal pour un couple de
s'embrasser c'est normal pour avoir un
noir dans une série télévisée c'est
normal sont rendus compte de plaine à
falla qui ont dû changer parce que
c'était vraiment
un médium très précis oui c'est sûr
maintenant où est ce qu'on peut trouver
des bonnes questions
rachid badouri points comme le font
depuis c'est super pratique
je veux juste faire une annonce spéciale
on a parlé a vécu que c'est pas de leur
faute ok ils ont été bien correct
billets.ca spectacle point sur toutes
ces sept là et on trouve des billets de
rachid badouri ac 120 pièces des biais
de josé houde à 95 et 140
jean-marc 180 trop quoi c'est ccd
revendeur puis je lui dois facebook pub
là dessus car les oliviers la haine de
son speech pour ça c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment vrai il ya vraiment des sites
de obscur commencé ma question c'est
vraiment des sites de revendeurs et et
on a parlé à ces sites là le hic apporte
aussi parce qu'ils échappent
c'est un peu un les packs e son
propriétaire du site ils ont leur site
ou ce qu'ils contrôlent les billets mais
il ya plein de monde qui achètent des
billets ils vont en acheter mais tandis
tout seul puis vont aller sur ce site là
pour l'heure à vendre super cher mais
c'est pas la faute du site web puisque
au début je pensais que c'était une
capote elle sylvie savard même entâché
de presse a les a appelés pika prothèses
non on trouve ça vraiment plate pour les
gens qui veulent vraiment des billets si
tu es si tu trouves en biais de rachid
badouri à 80 pièces sans pièces tepa sur
un bon site s'élargit badouri points
comme vos l'attitude cause par tête
toutes les billets qu'il faut sinon
c'était moi je me sentirai tellement mal
de savoir que j'ai fait payer 120 pièces
pour nous émouvoir savoure ce sont mes
pièces merci infiniment merci d'avoir
laissé place à cette liberté d'un losc
il n'y a pas eu d' interdit beaucoup ses
couvertures je te souhaite de continuer
dans cette belle merci un beau couple
non mais sérieux est un beau couple vous
êtes peut être le fun à regarder quand
on écoute quand on parle
vous avez une grande écoute ce que moi
j'ai dû apprendre à avoir longtemps je
t'adore par l'armée j'ai eu la musique
mon écoute vous êtes des grands
écouteurs semaine prochaine à bien
bientôt